[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et salut tout le monde bonjour à tous et
bienvenue pour cette douzième partie du
match de championnat du monde Fab et
bien c'est écrit 11 alors donc je ne
sais plus je ne sais plus quoi faire je
ne sais pas comment vivre Fab vite vite
parti numéro 12 on va le changer en
direct
c'est bon et je crois que qu'on rock
n'est pas digne
normalement ça dure mais
c'est si simple score exactement après
on se partit toujours un point d'écart
il nous en reste 3 et
digne à deux fois les blancs dont
aujourd'hui donc on va voir ce qu'il a
concocté quand on en parlait l'autre
jour on s'attendait peut-être un petit
D4 système de Londres ou KF3 fougères 5
mais avoir ce genre de structure
il a joué des quatre bon en rien ne dit
qu'il va sortir le fou vérification mais
on va voir
est-ce que Fab a été nostra Fabius
ou pas non est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
cinq déjà
et donc là peut-être
[Musique]
ouais pourquoi du coup bon de toute
façon on peut pas répéter le répertoire
de dépôt donc faut essayer de l'amener
sur un terrain qui sur lequel il a
montré qu'il était moins à l'aise et
franchement la partie sur le système de
Londres
bending a beaucoup mieux jouer avec lui
c'était clair et donc de l'amener dans
le genre de situation peut-être c'est
plus
c'est plus intéressant qu'un débat
théorique où il peut se faire sécher un
peu comme lors de la dernière partie
avec les Blancs donc il faut arriver à
oui avec les Blancs quand tu es anglaise
avec ses 4 4 donc arrivé à voilà faire
juste jouer l'adversaire dans une
position ou a priori il est peut-être un
peu moins à l'aise
et avoir voilà donc OK
stratégie plus ou moins logique de la
part de Ding et quelque chose qui
n'était pas forcément prévisible donc
c'est bien alors après il aura priori
pas davantage dans l'ouverture mais une
position qui va jouer alors si on
l'appelle le 3 poisons ce qui a un livre
avec un répertoire qu'il a qui s'appelle
le 3 poisons où il te disent de jouer D4
cavaliers F3 E3 dans n'importe quel
ordre
tu es très empoisonné et du coup tu mets
tu mets tes pièces et tu fais du poison
à fond donc c'est 5 cavaliers BD2 alors
ça paye pas de mine hein
et à juste titre puisque ça prétend pas
à prendre l'avantage
non mais en fait en gros tu joues un
grand bidame inversé
blanc donc déjà ça donne des options de
prendre en C5 peut-être d'accrocher
option de temps en temps
et puis bon enfin déjà ce qu'avec les
Noirs c'est solide et c'est correct de
dire avec les blondes attendent plus ça
peut pas être mal hein un deuxième point
positif que Vlad m'avait expliqué du
point fort c'est que comme par rapport
au slave t'as pas joué C3 tu as tout un
tas de variantes aussi ou comme tu
disais tu peux te permettre de prendre
en C5 et avoir pour t'accrocher au pion
et pour jouer du coup C4 et tu aurais
économisé par rapport au noir bah de
temps non seulement tu as un temps de
plus et en plus tu as aussi économiser
le le petit coup de Punto donc bon voilà
c'est très empoisonné c'est j'ai envie
de dire variante toxique
c'est très théorie toxique la manière de
jouer de Ding
et donc dis que je pense qu'il sera pas
mécontent si une époque venait à prendre
en D4 donc il reprenait du pion mais il
aurait la structure de carsbad sur
laquelle justement il a bien maîtrisé
l'autre jour donc c'est cool puis en
plus en termes de tempo tu es pas si mal
hein
donc
attends mais ça clique je crois
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu un bug c'est ce
que j'ai pris en même temps qui prenait
ok donc la souris donc je veux dire à
vrai dire c'est comme ça que nepo est
traité la position que tu lavé les
blancs
[Musique]
mais donc c'est pas si étonnant qui
rentre là-dedans mais en même temps
l'autre jour dans le système de Londres
Ding avec beaucoup mieux jouer genre de
position donc ok on va voir
comment ça se passe dames C7 jouer
nos plans envoyer un C4
[Musique]
tu joues plus pour ça que pour les plans
avec dessin que je ne sais quoi peut
faire ça alors ça me fait mal au cœur de
te lâcher cette info Fab
mais tu peux
je l'aurais pas fait mais tu peux songer
j'ai pas pris bêtements alors il fait
ces trois d'abord bon pourquoi pas de
toute façon
cavaliers 5 un peu à l'image de l'autre
partie
alors tu fais fou F5 ou tu fais 6
kg
moi
après tu peux aussi peut-être jouer avec
G6
[Musique]
il va pas faire normalement mais bon
je pense qu'elle va laisser six
ok 6 donc moi je te dirai fout des trois
mais j'en sais rien enfin
c'est le coup du coup on avait regardé
je te bouffe bon on me prend
tu recules
j'ai envie de te faire le coup
j'ai envie de te faire
je fais pas le coup de l'ordi
tu veux pas trop je me débloque pas du
tout
non je sais pas en fait
si tu veux je te dis pourquoi je l'ai
fait
ça maintenant
j'ai trois ça me faisait un peu chier
c'est pour ça que je te demandais quoi
je fais aussi mais bon bah là non tu as
plus le droit tu m'as dit que tu n'es
pas pour ça
non je n'ai pas pour ça moi je venais
pour
[Musique]
mais en fait je préfère
c'est pas bien ça positionnement
[Musique]
parce que quand tu le jour où tu fais ça
en fait il a peu de case hein
il peut sortir ou pas ouais mais tu vas
te faire enfin
que souvent en fait quand tu fais [__]
avec tu perds un temps reculé parce que
il est con avec 5 donc ça je c'est
horrible parce qu'en fait si tu viens en
F5 quand vient tu te fais attaquer E7
que tu dois faire aussi si ton fou il y
a plus de cas tu peux te prendre des f3g
non mais je pense que c'est l'idée qui
va laisser six fous B5
et si je fais pas si je crois créer un
et je fais
bon après il y a la deuxième il y a
quand même la deuxième option qu'on a
même pas regardé que j'aime pas trop
mais peut-être qu'il va ici c'est à 6
vous prend des prend
j'aime pas trop me mettre les pions
comme ça mais si en fait je peux te
refaire ces 5 et compagnie peut-être que
je peux faire mais ça ça peut être
dangereux oui mais 4
on développe
après la différence de l'autre partie
avec le même plan c'est que je contrôle
pas E5
pas bien
ça va arriver plus vite que la dernière
fois une tête assis ouais mais du coup
faut peut-être plus précis avec les
Blancs
c'est que au moins les pots n'a pas
l'air d'être
par cœur en fait j'aime bien une des
idées de l'ordi
de venir taper là
on prend déjà 6 non mais en fait je
voulais juste montrer l'idée que j'ai
peut-être des C4 aussi dans ce cas de
figure
à vrai dire ça ça peut être une grosse
idée bon là ça marche pas mais enfin
c'est juste pour illustrer oui là ça
peut vite bien tourner tu mets le fond
F4 machin
pour moi c'est un excellent choix de de
Ding ouais de faire jouer ce genre de
position
ça joue aux échecs
une position Ding a l'air nettement plus
à l'aise
et en autre chose dont on a pas parlé
c'est que vu la situation du match et la
tension qu'on a pu ressentir d'après les
coups de la partie précédente pour Yann
qui a envie de fermer un maximum la
porte là il garde toutes les pièces sur
les chéquiers en plus Ding ça fait jouer
il s'assure d'avoir toutes les pièces
sur les chiquer
en prenant le petit bout de papier elle
va être attirée par le bout de papier si
tu lui prends elle va être très heureuse
allez tellement maligne
et beaucoup plus intelligente que femme
ouais elle a compris le piège papier
essaie de sortir le chien
ouais d'un morceau de gorgonzola devrait
m'a faire l'affaire Fab dans frigidaire
en haut et ouais Fab à au prise avec le
chien
très intelligent ce chien
très très intelligent
dès qu'elle a entendu le bruit du
gorgonzola qui fait et qui sortait du
frigidaire elle est partie allez c'est
très très malin
allez c'est Fab qui aurait fini dehors
de la pièce non
il a fallu monter les enchères
et 13h du corps comme ça là je suis pas
sûr je lui ai donné bon je le pose par
terre
mais en fait c'est Mischa qui t'a fait
sortir
je vais le faire sortir en jouant avec
ce bout de papier
je pense qu'il va me donner un morceau
de gorgonzola au passage
c'est beau quoi ce fou B5 français 6 qui
fait suer mais après peut-être il va
faire [__] des trois tempos
oui mais tu peux vraiment voir cette
position comme ça
ok c'est pas une position qu'on aurait
vraiment mais on peut la voir c'est
légalement oui et voilà
d'ailleurs pourquoi il a fait si vite je
sais pas
en fait j'étais en train de me dire
juste pour expliquer le truc alors on va
faire une carroscane
j'étais en train de me dire que là
sur ces trois tu fais dames c'est 7 pour
éviter fu F4 tu peux mais si je pouvais
faire cavalier enfin si le mec me disait
je vais faire cavalier BD au prochain
coup ok je joue
donc
je me dis oui que ça c'est bizarre c'est
bizarre mais qu'il a pas fait cavalier
c'est 6 à cause de fou B5 peut-être
donc il s'est dit je vais faire dams
enfin il s'est dit rien du tout il a pas
réfléchi mais on pourrait se dire dame
C7 s'il bouge le fou pardon dans ces cas
là je mets les cavaliers en C6 il va
faire C3 tôt ou tard et j'ai enfin j'ai
ce que je voulais je sais pas quoi
j'imagine mais là en fait il veut pas
faire pousser s'il veut pas faire
cavalier 6 pour pas se prendre le fond
en dessin donc il doit faire fou F5 si
on suit cette logique là vous fougez 4
mais sur quoi là tu as peut-être du
cavalier E5 et du coup tu fais que ici
tu te reprends en fou B5 et si tu fais
si tu te reprends fou B5
je crois qu'il suffit de fou baisser
[Rires]
pour le spectateur je pense qu'il y aura
lieu 5 c'est vraiment fort là car il
sait si ce cavaliers F3 et fouf 4 Onex
et
et c'est beau en fait
c'est pas du dame B3 souvent
on peut le faire aussi
en fait ici j'ai 4 fois ici qui évaluent
c'est évident en fait c'est évident et
puis déjà enfin ouais c'est ok
ça c'est et sur qui est ici tu as aussi
des F4 qui peuvent être possible parfois
à regarder là c'est bon on va lui
refaire fou B5
c'est bizarre enfin le coup est pas
bizarre en soi enfin il peut que dans
genre situation mais là si vite pour
être tanka après ces trois c'est ouais
c'est trop Yann mais il devait avoir
dames c'est ça dans un fichier mais cela
dit bon je militerai quand même pour
caler ces 6 ah je pense que tu dois
faire qu'avec des C6 fou B5 ah bah il a
joué
il a joué
je suis complètement trouvé ça avec
c'est incroyable
oh mais c'est trop fou de cette en fait
ça ne peut pas être bon c'est forcément
un coup de merde c'est horrible ah mais
c'est horrible au pire si tu veux faire
ça fait aussi c'est le plan de guéri
c'est quoi le plan
j'appelle le plan Guiri parce que j'ai
dans ma base de données sur les karaokes
des changes et je sais qu'il y a guéri
qui a joué comme ça donc moi je
l'appelle le plan Guiri mais fou des
sept en fait c'est parce qu'à vrai dire
si tu cailles ici il fait fou B5 ça te
fait t'en suer au pire tu fais foudre
maintenant d'ailleurs
non mais foutez cette là c'est très
honnêtement
je vais encore me faire tacler par la
moitié d'Internet mais je vois une
partie comme ça devinez le hello je
donne pas plus de 1500 hello noir en
fait
là je comprends pourquoi il a joué mais
en soit le coup il est ridicule enfin
non c'est pas un coup du jeu d'échec
c'est vraiment ridicule mais
non mais genre le coup enfin c'est bien
sûr tout seul et mauvais souvenir de la
partie qui l'a perdu et il veut pas
revenir le truc et parce que mais c'est
ouais c'est fou d'être si vite
c'est un des pires coups que j'ai vu en
match du championnat du monde je pense
stratégique
bon après peut-être il va la tenir et
que mais bon là il va jouer 2008 et il
va jouer une très bonne partie Anne
c'est pas ça le cas mais bon fou des 7
c'est ça n'appartient pas un champion du
monde ce coup non
quand tu fais ça
tu as envie de te prendre un saut de
vomi et te le mettre sur la tête non
quand tu fous des 7 mais là il est
dégoûté de lui-même tu es dégoûté de
toi-même tu fais ça ça nous arrive à
tous de faire ça Fab moi surtout moi ça
m'est arrivé de faire des trucs comme ça
mais Fab aussi bien sûr
mais tu as envie de te vomir dessus
quand c'est ça non
[Musique]
et
non mais c'est horrible il y a de
l'ordre
pourquoi c'est si horrible bah il est
pas très bien on essaie de le fou toi tu
as envie en haut avec les Noirs tu as
envie de jouer avec eux aussi pour
développer toute case noire et que ton
foodcas blanche soit pour mur est
derrière parce que tu vas te prendre des
problèmes donc
en fait toi tu joues avec eux aussi et
tu sais que les Blancs ont peut-être
attaquer sur les rois et comme Kef
disait tu peux essayer de développer le
foot l'autre diagonale et peut-être
c'est une pièce en E4 ou quoi bon même
si c'était plutôt rare mais pourquoi pas
ou sinon bah tu le sors vers l'avant et
puis c'est la vie quoi mais tu mets
surtout pas en dessert en fait mais déjà
tous ces 8 c'est juste la même chose
donc tu as plus ou moins passé ton tour
en fait il est mieux en C8 parce que B7
c'est un vrai plan faudrait que je
retrouve les parties de guéris
[Musique]
et donc voilà donc là quand tu fais ce
plan tu mets le fou en B7 et tu peux
jouer bon suivant tu peux jouer avec le
Cavaillon D7 pour essayer de faire
cavalier 4 cavalier F6 et qui a validé 6
donc en fait ça ça c'est horrible ça
c'est c'est horrible bah ça va pas trop
ensemble quoi voilà est-ce que ça peut
faire H3 pour punir en fait tu es
content
vraiment avec un tempo noir dit il
propose carrément fougère mais du coup
ça enfin il va pas le faire enfin bon
peut-être mais quoi qu'il en soit bah au
pire on te fait fou des seins qu'on perd
un temps aussi vite est-ce que tu
voulais pas en fait enfin on va quand
même pas faire Flober 5 ici mais
bon bah Ding qui joue normal il se prend
pas trop la tête c'est plutôt bien il
cherche pas chercher les détails à faire
45 minutes
ce que je trouve intéressant quand même
c'est la toxicité du joueur qui fait mal
jouer l'autre deux trois présents mais
c'est toxique quoi
et du coup ça ouais mais tu toxifie
c'est un petit peu ce qui est arrivé à
Bachir au championnat d'Europe surtout
au début comme il avait été au contact à
mon contact pendant longtemps ses
adversaires jouaient mal au début de
tournoi et il avait réussi à gagner de
très très belles parties par sa toxicité
d'ailleurs on avait fait une miniature
il était très toxique on voyait un peu
verdâtre on voyait de la toxicité qui
sortait de Baki
mais là le 3 il y a un coût très toxique
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait il joue le truc pour
juste voir une partie des chèques en
fait il a une partie d'échec et en plus
il est mieux c'est même pas que c'est
égal quoi d'ailleurs pour la petite
anecdote donc ça n'intéresse que moi
mais peu importe dans le title j'ai fait
une contre Magnus je vais battu tout le
monde avec les Blancs j'avais joué le 3
poisons à toutes les parties sauf
campagne
des résidus de toxicité qui restaient
trois poisons dommage que j'ai pas le
livre
trois poisons
étaient très heureux
non mais basiquement c'est pas c'est pas
de mauvaises ouvertures bah là on voit
un match championnat du monde tu as pas
besoin enfin quand on nous dit souvent
sur sur internet tu poses la question
machin à partir de quel niveau il faut
connaître la théorie la honnêtement Ding
il joue sans théorie non bah il connaît
les idées mais voilà il s'en fout en
fait il veut une partie sans théorie
finale de championnat du monde le mec
c'est enfermé six mois à travailler les
ouvertures tiens regarde je veux pas
d'ouverture je suis quand même mieux non
mais
mais là soit hyper inconfortable pour ne
pas mais je sais pas
[Musique]
pour vous dire qu'on dit pas n'importe
quoi
au moins il a pas laissé le fond de ça
va être ultra analysé à partir de
maintenant le 3 poisons bah ça peut être
le problème c'est qu'ils sont capables
de tout apprendre par cœur une énième
fois sur une énième ouverture et tu peux
de nouveau plus jouer juste aux échecs
nous avec Fab c'est quelque chose qu'on
regrette clairement parce que là enfin
c'est tellement agréable les échecs
quand les mecs pouvaient pas tout te
réciter par cœur si tu joues déjà sur
les idées c'est hyper intéressant
beaucoup plus intéressant que faire les
automatons et réciter mais bon c'est les
échecs modernes malheureusement
ça perd quand même un temps important
faisait cette fougères 4 ah bah c'est
sûr que les blancs sont mieux là mais
après c'est peut-être une bonne décision
pratique qui a pris Yann nepomashi et de
d'éviter une position qui joue vraiment
mal
on soit c'est pas idiot mais
je dois dire Fab que d'un autre côté
enfin juste par principe si on peut
jouer aux échecs comme ça en fait ça me
dégoutterait que Yann perdent pas cette
partie juste pour les échecs en fait
que ce soit possible de faire ça en
match championnat du monde ça me dégoûte
en fait bah on va dire
parce que ça ça doit être puni quand
même ouais mais c'est peut-être pas
assez grave pour être super mal témoins
tu joues tous les bons coups privé tu
perds pas mais ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est que basiquement si tu commences
par mal jouer dès le début ce serait
étonnant que tout d'un coup tu joues
tout parfum c'est qu'il y a un truc qui
tourne pas rond et que tu peux enchaîner
non mais tu sais ça me fait penser à la
phrase de spaski les échecs ne
pardonnent pas enfin genre si tu
pardonnes ça en fait c'est
je crois que tu pardonne
genre normalement tu dois pas perdre un
tel truc fais juste les dieux des échecs
sauf te punir pour avoir fait ça un fou
des sept fougères ça appartient pas un
match de championnat du monde point
barre en fait ou alors c'est trop subtil
pour nous mais bon je crois pas mais
c'est pas subtil mais juste tu peux pas
être champion du monde en jouant ça
quand même c'est trop faible
Magnus revient
bon du coup Ding ça y réfléchit
non mais basiquement on a envie de faire
un coup de dame alors dans ma carte
pourquoi pas est-ce que Damien tu peux
pour faire quelques cinq aussi
mais bon du coup j'ai fait quand même te
faire dame B3 tu vas revenir enfin au
bout d'un moment
j'ai juste envie de te punir parce que
d'habitude la réaction normale sur
darmacade c'est fou des 7 oui donc là
j'ai envie de te dire bon ben tu vas
faire un troisième coup de fou
si tu veux mais
si tu fais aussi ce qui a value 5 et je
te reprends
de ces 6 aussi pour te faire la mauvaise
structure non mais bon enfin c'est pas
sérieux au pire je te fais ça ça et ça
on est plutôt mieux
on va voir notre attaque elle est le roi
et
puis c'est cool
non mais dans ma carte ça l'air très
bien
bah c'est le plus logique parce que
c'est un antidote enfin c'est ce qui
vient le plus souligner les coudes
vertes quoi
[Musique]
au bout d'un moment ça
ça va c'est trop quoi je sais pas
j'aurais pas l'impression d'être plus
que ça avec les Noirs mais
peut-être tu es pas obligé de me faire
aussi non plus hein
[Musique]
avec les Noirs
ils sont assez des coups de principe où
tu veux tu dis bon bah tu es mal
développé tu as bougé plusieurs fois la
même pièce dans l'ouverture je vais
ouvrir le jeu j'arrive mais
on arrive vraiment je sais pas ça c'est
la question mais bon mais c'est juste
cavaliero 5 je le prépare
n'oubliez pas il y a ce truc là qui est
un thème qui est pénible pour les Noirs
ok si on joue le coup de l'ordi il faut
acheter au bout d'un moment
enfin je vais faire voilà je vais te
faire foudre tu vas la voir la structure
au bout d'un moment
je vais essayer de te forcer ce serait
dur que tu veux éviter tout à l'heure
alors là je vois pas trop vite mais
32D t'as pas envie alors attendez
ça un jour je sais plus quoi on était là
pardon
et trop long
[Musique]
et moi j'avais tenté chez plus quoi
je me sens
je crois qu'on avait 17 d'abord
qui coupe dans l'autre sens tu reviens
le droit
en fait j'ai une structure
ça me fait penser à la variante là avec
le dame
[Musique]
c'est un truc comme ça cavalier F6 C4
c'est 6 cavaliers des deux mais il y a
pas le cas ici
bon là c'est pire que ce qu'on regarde
mais il y a des trucs aussi avec les
Noirs
c'est pas mal
il peut pas faire de 6 il va arriver les
trucs en B5 à 4 et que
ça me met mal quoi
je vois pas ce que tu laisses mais
je te répète les couilles
cette fois-ci tu fais tout hein
aujourd'hui je vais jouer vite
parce que nous on le on le regarde pas
et dans ma carte ça paraissait tellement
logique
par curiosité empire on peut regarder
nous si je disais bien dans la cadre
mais bizarre ce début de partie
ça joue pas les coups logiques
bon chez Ding ça va à peu près mais oui
dans ma 4 c'était le truc tu as le plus
envie de faire mais après l'un dans
l'autre ça reste de transposer parce que
tourin on voyait mal ou la tour elle est
à l'aide d'autres de toute façon
et là je peux peut-être repartir avec
vous les 5
ah mais je menace pas de prendre parce
qu'il y a ça en l'air à la finitions
[Musique]
ok il joue pour autre chose mais
c'est moins direct mais c'est logique il
veut fouder 6 qui est G3 petit rock ça
c'est normal et H3 vous prenez trois
dames 3
mais ça je peux comprendre que ça aille
pour les noirs
[Musique]
on va peut-être faire ces quatre un jour
peut-être F3 pour ouvrir ailleurs
peut-être on va faire B3 avant
ok bon on va voir comment
ça peut s'entendre souvent c'est une
réaction de tous ces pions à choix
contre une pièce en G3 en B3 et donc
charger 3 il veut prendre G3 HG
hgfg prise on aura fait plein
de toute façon ça sent qu'on veut pas
rentrer là-dedans il a joué fou G5
les choses qui jouent hyper vite enfin
que là il avait quand il a fait tourner
un cavalier F1
non mais
ils sont posés en fait ils sont arrêtés
de réfléchir à des
moments bizarres mais oui il a sûrement
des coups mais
[Musique]
déjà 11e coup la partie ça fait une
demi-heure que ça joue donc ça a cliqué
vite alors l'ouverture
ça joue vite je trouve
tu la sens la grosse gaffe dans cette
partie arriver d'un côté ou de l'autre
j'en sais rien
[Musique]
il y aura un truc pour je viens d'avoir
une idée là pour que les joueurs ils
partent moins en salle de repos ouais
dis-moi ce serait de faire des tops à la
vachette dans les salles de repos tu
vois
[Rires]
réponse sur ton canapé quoi est-ce que
tu as des points bonus pour citer
esquive un peu la vachette ça donnerait
tout son sens à la caméra dans la salle
de repos où le mec il va pour se reposer
plus d'un coup de top à la machette quoi
et tu su quoi et d'ailleurs on leur
ferme la porte avec les et pour
s'échapper il doit faire l'épreuve des
bars pour pour monter et partir quoi
ouais ce serait beau le top à la
machette qui part quoi
le mur des champions du monde
tu me montres
[Rires]
[Musique]
in franchement ça donnerait un peu de
cachet à s'échappement dans les
vachettes façon je pense les vachettes
tu les mets dans n'importe quoi
tu peux faire n'importe quoi donc il y a
la vachette qui arrive c'est mieux quoi
j'adore rien quoi
j'étais un grand fan des vaches moi
j'étais tout le temps pour la vache hein
mais j'étais sympa les vachettes
ouais vas-y certaines tu les voyais
c'est très énervé
tu sentais que bon
mais ne peut partir sur du grand qu'un
nouveau je pense qu'il devrait ah voilà
il fait comme je suis en partie
pédagogique il te fait H6 et il te
regarde tu vas prendre il te battre
en partie pédagogique à 1500 ça marche
toujours ça je te donne ton tour
de la partie 2
il va y penser il va faire quoi
[Musique]
oui mais bon
donc
non peut-être faire petit rock mais
je sais pas ça a l'air soupçonnant
il y a plus de H5 évidemment maintenant
que le roi est parti de ce côté là il y
a plus la tourelle
et on fait acheter le coup d'après on
prend la paire de fou et leur dit
comment ça faire des trucs bizarres
cavaler H5
il a fait il a fait rock OK
bon
il a fait rock je continue à penser que
dans ma carte était plus fort mais bon
je suis direct
stagne qui aurait jamais ok moi ça
m'aurait pas dérangé ok personnellement
bon c'est un bon coup pour nous embêter
on n'a pas H3 facilement
après faut prendre F3 et il est trop
nombreux sur G3
et on perd un pion alors quand même
regarder
parce que j'ai envie de dire il y a du
monde au balcon
genre taureau trois fois
je m'enlève le pion H3
mais bon même ça c'est pas clair du tout
non non
peut-être que Ding a vraiment mal joué
là la série de coup
ouais
on est un peu comment dire ce qui fait
Ding on comprend que tu veux que j'ai 3
mais si il y a quel âge 5 est empêche
c'est chiant et du coup on préfère le
crayon des deux pour bouger la dame et
caillot 5 parce que là en fait on est
très mal joué en fait
[Musique]
que Ding a sous-est en fait il s'est dit
il faut G5 je te prends un F6 tu peux
pas ok de manière superficielle que
c'est enfin franchement faut prendre F6
je les prends F6 tu l'as dans les
carreaux Cannes donc c'est pas enfin
genre c'est pas le plan le plus
inattendu de l'année quand même
surtout que le fou il peut revenir en G6
pour colmater franchement c'est pas très
franchement la l'ouverture les deux ont
mal joué enfin non mais quand je dis que
ça se joue vite
parce qu'ils font tu cliques des coups
ils ont juste des cours en fait ouais
c'est vraiment
c'est la pression du
championnats pourries c'est un bon choix
psychologique
étonnamment quoi
je suis un peu déçu
un peu déçu de l'ouverture parce que
bon après c'est une partie ça va jouer
au pire c'est idéal
j'aime bien quand ça joue bien en fait
du coup tu restes assis 4 4 5 heures
devant une partie c'est pour voir une
belle partie c'est pas pour voir un truc
que tu pourrais voir dans un title
Tuesday non mais tu vois
qui t'a joué long autant avoir des
belles parties c'est ce que disait
d'ailleurs du bof
ouais il a dit c'est un beau match pour
les spectateurs mais pour les pros
franchement
bon après je sais pas bah non mais je
discute
non mais ça joue bien mais genre là
c'est là je suis devant je suis un peu
déçu la femme
la fin du championnat du monde c'est un
peu le c'est un peu le tie-break
de l'Australian Open et les mecs bon les
jeux c'est que des fautes directes tu
vois c'est dommage alors que le fedenas
justement il est beau parce qu'à un
moment donné les mecs ils mettent plus
de balle dehors
tu atteint le climax final du tennis ou
les mecs bon tu savent plus sortir une
balle en fait ils sont là tu as tout qui
rentre dans le cours
du coup là pour le climax c'est un peu
dommage ouais c'est comme si bon de
double faute l'autre il met de retour
dans le filet bon non mais tu vois plus
rien
alors c'est le moment où tu espères bah
après c'est comme ça c'est le sport on
commande pas les joueurs font de leur
mieux bien évidemment
mais c'est ouais
une question sur un coup peut-être
intéressant
je peux s'entendre comme quoi et on nous
demande est-ce que tu as fait en une
carotane mais là on a pas déjà transposé
dans une carrocane bah tu peux avoir des
trucs par transposition mais là non tu
as pas transposé puisque tu fais jamais
fouder cette fougères dans la carroscan
mais oui c'est la même structure d'une
carotane d'échange enfin aux échecs on
peut avoir des positions en venant de
beaucoup d'ouverture différente tu as
aussi des Nimes zoos qui transposent des
karaokes enfin
beaucoup de transposition aux échecs
globalement
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je dis que dans une
carrocane il y a le fou prend F6 donc
c'est pas une position inconnue au
bataillon c'est plutôt même une position
très connue enfin un style de position
très connu des échecs là qu'ils ont bah
c'est juste une structure cards c'est
peut-être la structure la plus jouée de
enfin c'est l'histoire la plus jouée des
matchs du championnat du monde c'est sûr
de loin la structure cards
ils ont fait que ça
et les cartes peuvent casse-toi c'est
beaucoup de gambidas
donc je sais pas déjà tout ça sans faire
un peu ici ou là après c'est une des
structures de base des échecs donc tu es
censé connaître quasiment tous les plans
qui existent et le plan FG GF c'est un
plan qui est relativement connu
ça peut arriver quoi bah tu sais que
c'est possible
donc c'est étonnant d'avoir joué de
cette manière là pour Ding parce que
clairement comme tu le disais il a misé
sur le fait que sur Rock il avait [__]
F6 qui donne avantage mais voilà sans
regarder en fait
on prend et cavalier G3 peut-être du
coup essayer ça quand même un système je
suis vite H3 vous prend F3 dans F3
F5 et ouais je vois cette position
mais tu es pas mieux
on joue quoi bon ben oui
bon ça peut très bien être ça la partie
j'étais en train de me dire la même
chose que je l'ai mis
c'est peut-être fait son talon d'Achille
sous-estime légère
c'est vrai que ça fait deux fois dans le
match et c'est deux fois dans des
positions c'est un coût thématique
dans le domaine du possible il
sous-estime et je prends FX
il faudrait qu'il regarde tes vidéos
premium sur chascom sur les pions
doubles
[Musique]
G3
un truc qu'on jouera jamais il fait
cavalier 3G 3 fois 2
[Musique]
3 boum
ok c'est probable en fait c'est vraiment
une chatte coup normal est-ce que ça ça
marche
j'aurais du mal à penser être mieux avec
les Blancs
je pense pas qu'il va le faire
mais tu as raison faut regarder parce
que si ça marche ma statue mais c'est
pas le cas
bon est-ce qu'on fait rocher est-ce
qu'on fait cavalier H5 est-ce qu'on
paraissait logique
bon et là faut trouver
les blancs serait pas un peu moins bien
en fait
en tout cas c'est plus facile à jouer
avec les Noirs s'il y a le droit le plus
faible en fait je vais arriver je vais
te faire Tanger sister G8 faites tous
mes coups sont hyper logique avec les
Noirs je suis peut-être pas moins bien
mais c'est tellement simple à jouer
après je peux même avoir le plan de te
faire Kiper vite et des 7 cavaliers
[Musique]
sera facilement chassée par une tour en
G6
et la colonne g c'est les noirs qui en
profite pas les blancs
intéressants ou pas
[Musique]
mais peut-être on peut le tolérer
sur fouille
on va comme
moi je pense très honnêtement je pense
que ça avantage noir
plus on regarde plus si je devais
prendre une couleur ici je prendrai les
noirs
d'ailleurs ça m'étonne pas que le coup
de l'ordi du coup ce soit 4
changer l'autre et oui mais bon enfin et
non mais c'est je suis écœuré je suis au
cœur et les amis je suis vraiment écœuré
premier degré c'est
j'ai pas d'autres mots
c'est un truc c'est ça me rend triste en
fait de voir ça
d'avoir un truc comme foot et cette
fougère et quand final du championnat du
monde se soit pas puni ça me fait que 8
coups après c'est déjà non mais
ça m'agace quoi vraiment c'est pas
normal en fait
on est là pour José chèques on n'est pas
là pour cliquer des coups au hasard
mais j'aurais pas fait mieux que lui ou
peut-être j'aurais fait mieux ou j'en
sais rien mais mais juste j'ai envie de
voir ces trucs puni en fait ça me ça me
procure un plaisir et là voir un truc
comme ça pas puni et genre en mode ouais
bon bah quatre coups après tu es bien
avec les Noirs ça me rend fou en fait ça
me rend fou
je sais pas s'il y a que moi qui suis
comme ça ou si vous partagez mon avis
sur dans le chat donc je remonte un la
séquence mais il te fait un tel coup de
plot de foot et 7 pour éviter les
foulées 5 par phobie fout des trois qui
est le fond G4 donc il perd un tempo net
dans l'ouverture pour rien et digne le
refus de pas du tout il se retrouve même
moins bien 4 coups après ça me rend fou
bon moi bien c'est pas sûr mais en tout
cas pas mieux
ça me rend tellement triste
on y passe ça punir ça montre que Ding
neuf mérite pas mieux non mais je suis
d'accord avec ça mais c'est une finale
de championnat du monde les amis c'est
pas
on n'est pas en train de faire un bide
au café du commerce quoi
c'est pas c'est juste ça c'est que tu
passes des heures à commenter à regarder
à machin un truc et tu as juste envie
pour les échecs en fait là c'est
enfin moi c'est pour la beauté des
échecs que j'ai envie de voir ça c'est
pas je m'en fiche soit Ding ou nepo qui
gagne honnêtement ça me change rien du
tout enfin c'est je finis plus pour
lundi plus pour l'autre je suis pour les
échecs en fait mais ça ça me rend ouais
ça mange juste triste
non là c'est pas rater un pédo en fait
c'est tu tires le pédo et tu tu fais un
drop s'y mettre au dessus du but en fait
bon
10 minutes après pour l'autre équipe
puis l'autre il te refait pareil bon je
regarde le match oui bon enfin c'est
final de Coupe du Monde c'est c'est
Kylian Mbappe ou c'est ou c'est
Jean-Michel aime Papo quoi enfin
tu sais quoi oui mais Harry Kane bien
sûr mais du coup c'est la France qui
enfin je sais pas on le punit quoi voilà
il te fait arrêter et après il est là à
danser
j'ai raté trois penalty dans le match
j'étais quand même battu
aime pas trop ouais c'est ça
Jean-Michel aime pas beau
mais donc voilà ça c'est pour ça que ça
me ça me rend un peu triste mais rien
contre les joueurs c'est juste que on
est là pour voir du beau jeu quoi ou tu
vois tu regardes le Tour de France tu as
le premier qui chute tu as le deuxième
qui chute tu as le 3e qui chute mais
même pas en descend tout quoi alors les
mecs ils montent l'Alpe d'Huez
ça montre trop pour lui il descend du
vélo il pousse du coup
c'est Van art ou devant un art la
surprise de ce Tour de France qui a
remporté l'Alpe d'Huez devant
poggatcharge et Romain Bardet
faire longtemps maintenant donc à
contretemps ce qui
va pas mais c'est comme ça il peut être
on peut faire notre première pause très
bientôt pendant cette réflexion on va
attendre on va attendre 11h50 dans 2
minutes dans 2 minutes
mais je pense pas qu'il aura choisi là
ça me fait penser à Thibaut Pinot qui
avait perdu le Tour de France parce que
c'était mis le guidon dans le ça c'était
incroyable te rappelle pas l'année où
Bernard a gagné donc Pino il était quand
même en forme montante il a eu défoncé
ça se sentait qu'il était plus fort et
c'était mis un coup de en pédalant il
s'était pris le la cuisse dans le guidon
c'est vraiment ça c'est tu te mets tu
fais du vélo et tu te blesses contre ton
guidon quoi oh tu dois pas être bien
quand même
c'est ah tu dois être écœuré quoi
comme Rico ça y est autour de Romandie
est hors de Romandie hier c'est un
inconnu total qui a gagné fin total les
gens les connaisseurs connaissent mais
c'est nul parce que nous regardez la
preview du truc on lisait le mec qui
avait fait un truc très détaillé
qui a gagné enfin il doit être dégoût
enfin c'est hyper intéressant ce qu'il
écrit mais bon ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'il te dit
aujourd'hui en sprint ça a été un sprint
il te dit qu'il te dit victoire soit de
Gaviria
Bernadette que je connais pas ou Vermont
ou je sais pas quoi donc en fait tu es
sûr que c'est aucun des trois qui
déjà normalement quand même c'est un
sprint ça il devrait trouver
le top c'est le cycliste qui était loin
devant et s'est trompé d'itinéraires à
la fin
[Musique]
ouais après j'ai un peu regardé du coup
sur sur Wikipédia il avait déjà gagné un
champion championnat de République
tchèque de contre la montre mais lui il
te dit qu'il est pas très surpris je
suis en grosse forme je vous conseille
cette année normalement je visais top 5
aujourd'hui
je me souviens enfin de toute façon
c'est toujours mieux que tu aies
confiance en toi quand
tu es sportif de haut niveau j'ai
l'impression que tous les sportifs de
haut niveau une énorme confiance en eux
à chaque fois que tu utilises une
interview quoi
alors que le mec personne l'a annonçait
même pas besoin moi je pensais vraiment
top 5 aujourd'hui bon minimum j'en ai
très déçu de faire top 10
le TGV de Clermont quoi
mais en plus cavania qui est hyper fort
en contre la montre alors que c'est
étonnant bah tu es personne en fait mais
je pense je suis beaucoup plus fort que
lui d'ailleurs
bon allez on se fait cette petite pause
et on revient on verra s'il fait le fou
prime F6F mais ça paraît ouais les Noirs
ont déjà plus égalisé ici enfin en tout
cas on égalisé on peut être une position
plus facile à jouer
merci à tous et à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour mesdames et messieurs
il y a toujours pas de coups jouets et
ouais Dink s'est rendu compte de sa
bêtise c'est terrible pour lui à mon
avis il a tellement mal joué Fab cette
série de couilles il le sait
on remontre un moment important de la
partie à la sortie de l'ouverture donc
il fait le système call 3 poisons
échange d'AMS C7 C3 ici Yann qui a
énormément réfléchi qui était inquiet
après cavalier C6 de fou B5 qui décide
de faire fouter cette fout des trois
puis cavalier C6 rock et fougère donc
évidemment très mal joué dans
l'ouverture de la part de Yann
erreur
mentale j'ai envie de dire les nerfs qui
n'ont pas tenu il a pas voulu revoir le
même type de position qu'il avait mené à
la défaite et ici digne qui refuse de
jouer le coup logique d'Ama 4 qui vient
appuyer sur cette diagonale laissez
vacantes par le fou qui n'allait pas
revenir une troisième fois en D7 il
décide de partir pour un autre plan
simplement il a très mal évalué la
position après rock et vient de jouer
fou 6 mais c'est la position qu'il a mal
évalué de base parce qu'après GF joué
tempo Parian bah le roi va venir en H8
la tour en G8 et c'est peut-être même
les noirs qui peuvent prétendre à l'épis
un avantage mais une position plus
facile fable donc un début de partie
complètement raté de la part des deux
joueurs qui sont complètement passés à
travers finalement ouais donc plus Ding
je dirais
de faire un mauvais choix explicable ça
reste un mauvais choix a priori il faut
des 7 mais
on comprend le mindset qu'il avait et
pourquoi il a voulu éviter et voilà
par contre Ding qu'on disait je vais
vite
quelque chose de pas terrible
pensant de manière superficielle que
donc après fougères 5 il allait empêché
le rock il empêche rien du tout c'est la
même erreur que dans la partie 2 quand
il avait oublié un GF et du coup
[Musique]
rayonnant il est là il danse il fait il
fait ça enfin tu peux le faire aussi si
tu veux je sais que tu as envie qu'il
est content aussi
et qui est en train de danser avec la
tour qui arrive
bah très franchement je me demande même
si la meilleure chance des blancs
finalement c'est pas de rentrer dans
cette variante quasiment forcée d'aller
tout liquider et d'essayer de prendre
nul ici parce que finalement c'est pas
ça le choix pratique
toute façon c'est le genre de solution
dont tu parlais donc la masse de pion
qui qui réduit toute caisse blanche
mais avec G4 mais c'est double tranchant
évidemment tu veux péter F5 pour trouver
la diagonale mais
bon tu as regardé
aussi un truc si vous regardez qui a le
plus de pions devant son roi mais
finalement c'est le roi noir qui a ce
pion H7 qui fait une énorme différence
après bon j'ai en position faite
compliqué après aussi le droit à chacun
on peut aller vers F1 pour couvrir de
l'autre côté
en tout cas
peut-être ça la meilleure option
finalement
et tenter de partir de l'autre côté et
c'est ce genre de position qui doit
jouer mais c'est double tranchant
on sait pas mais voilà quand tu le
disais quand même dommage vu l'aubaine
qui allait dans l'ouverture de pouvoir
prendre l'avantage après le simple
d'amac4 alors c'était pas un avantage
écrase en gagnant mais juste bah tu es
content tu as joué six coups tu es déjà
mieux
[Musique]
on va voir ouais je pense que ça
appartient en une position comme ça
alors après il peut il peut il peut Ding
donc organise cette partie tout peut
arriver à la position est complexe mais
c'est vrai que l'ouverture
oh ça a pas été du grand niveau mais bon
c'est comme ça après ça va faire un
combat de rue et donc tout peut arriver
ça peut être retour dans le match ça
peut être nul ça peut être fin du match
aussi quasi
en cas de victoire de
ouais mais c'est intéressant quand même
un devoir que quand on sort du Parker
les ouvertures il y a encore beaucoup de
d'erreurs à faire sur l'échiquier et ça
c'est plutôt intéressant je demande
faute
je demande aux
alors ça directement c'est ouais ça va
pas trop passer ouais c'est pour ça
qu'on fait H3 on veut se débarrasser de
foot caisse blanche et on gagne quand
même des cases pour le cas les G3 etc
doit être dépité ouais Vlad il doit être
dépité
ça doit le mettre tellement mal
tu joues avec les blancs de la partie 14
ce sera de nouveau digne il aura les
Noirs dans la partie 13 il y en aura
donc les pièces blanches s'ils font du
aujourd'hui on s'attend à une nul rapide
ouais dans la partie 13 et c'est pour
tout pour être se jouer dans cette 14e
partie
mais oui une ouverture décevante mais
bon ça nous offre une position
déséquilibrée donc ça peut nous offrir
une belle partie cependant comme on le
disait un peu plus tôt en match de
championnat du monde
on aimerait avoir des des parties
bien joué de A à Z
vous doit y en train de me dire E5 enfin
juste une variante un peu bête mais
genre ça j'aurai l'impression que tu
reprends le cas de gagne
95 c'est pour faire F600 et là du coup
on tape partout
n'a pas essayé de retourner dans un
système de Londres dommage bah il a
obtenu mieux encore c'est juste qu'il a
mal joué mais il a obtenu un style de
position de système de Londres améliorer
en cas de départage
du radir bon après une époque doit se
sentir en confiance puisque
puisqu'il fait pas tout pour l'éviter
enfin en fait en gros il compte l'éviter
en ne perdant plus mais il cherche pas
absolument à remarquer encore un point
quand il a des blancs donc il doit se
sentir favori mais je sais pas si
concrètement il l'est vraiment faut pas
oublier que que digne avait battu Magnus
en départage estinkelfield alors je sais
plus quand ces tests en 2019 sûrement
2020 mais 2019 je pense mais
ça faisait une éternité avec Magnus
t'avais pas perdu un match de départage
donc Ding il séjour en rapide quoi
c'est équilibré à mon avis en rapide ce
qui est sûr c'est que nepo doit penser
qu'il est favori mais c'est pas le cas
mais ouais après ça vendait partage ça
va pas jouer que sur la valeur
intrinsèque des joueurs il y a beaucoup
de
de gestion des nerfs de plein de choses
parce qu'en fait il y aura sûrement un
impôt quand même déçu genre s'il parle à
14e de voir son adversaire revenir mais
c'est pas parce que tu es égalise que tu
as gagné enfin c'est comme
je sais pas prenons la France à la Coupe
du monde en fait tu es heureux quand tu
étais mené de zéro à la 90e en gros mais
tu as fait que la moitié du chemin enfin
pas encore gagné la théorie quoi donc
faut pas te souffler et donc je sais pas
tu vois enfin il y aura aussi toute
cette gestion là
parfois c'est étonnant ça tu as
l'impression que celui qui revient il a
un gros avantage mais en réalité quand
tu regardes en fait d'effort de revenir
que des fois c'est l'inverse
c'est de la discussion de comptoir mais
en gros tout ça pour dire je sais pas
qui serait favori quoi si on en est
arrivé là et a priori d'ailleurs il y
aurait même objectivement pas tellement
de favoris dans le sens où après 14
parties ce serait pas vraiment
départagés il y a eu cette scène donc de
jouer à peu près pareil voilà alors à
l'époque quand c'était Magnus contre
karwana on savait parce que
là il y a pas de différence entre un sac
de niveau différence
donc
quand il joue bah écoute il a encore une
heure et demie là pour réfléchir je vous
quand il veut il va jouer avoir une
lumière qui vient
ce qu'il fait il fait F5 qui fait en H8
il fait Tanger V8 avec les Noirs mais il
regarde la variante qu'on a il doit
calculer
de pièces regarder des trucs comme ça et
puis voilà
une statistiquement quand un joueur
remonte de 7 à rien il perd le 5e ouais
ça c'est vrai
j'avais aussi lu tu as l'impression que
tu étais à zéro tu reviens à 2-2 que bon
tu as l'énergie employée pour revenir au
score parfois il te manque
ce qui est contre intuitif
mais je pense que H5 G4 et peut-être 3f1
peut-être après avoir égalisé ouais mais
des fois une fois que tu as égalisé tu
changes un peu aussi de
risquer ou je sais pas tu vas en faire
trop au contraire tu es sur ton truc et
puis l'autre il ferme quoi je sais pas
comment dire mais
pas bon du coup ça veut rien dire en
fait voilà tout ça pour dire que oui ça
pour dire tout ça pour dire que il y a
rien à dire
[Musique]
il se trouve que a priori c'est jouable
d'après notre petit jardin
pas regarder le coup
après je sais pas ça se trouve un truc
comme ça
qui part mais je serais étonné enfin ça
me semble clair qu'il va faire f538 vous
vice Versailles mais tu vas partir sur
cette plat mec avec les Blancs il va
essayer de faire h3g4 donc très double
tranchant et plutôt avec le roi et fin
que H
pas à ce que nepo veut jouer mais c'est
pas une question nulle rapidement là ce
retard c'est juste un coup qu'on regarde
pas parce que c'est
trop bizarre mais après j'ai trois pions
je sais pas trop quoi en dire
on peut voir mettre la position
[Musique]
7 donc il faut défendre ce fou d'une
autre manière donc tu auras des 8 et on
reprend F6 tu reprends à me prendre à me
G7
genre que ça vaut en fait exactement ça
moi j'aurais été capable de rentrer
là-dedans
non en fait oui enfin je sais pas trop
quoi en penser
j'aime pas ce qu'on veut exactement
je retourne est-ce que tu pars sur MG4
ou tu gardes c'est déjà une question en
fait
je pense ton roi est plus faible que le
mien en vrai
rentrer là dans la finale
enfin
[Musique]
qui est faible et que si je le si je le
garde parce que je suis gagnant en fait
ici à faire [__] de g3f4 F3 G2
on avance
en fait je pense que je risque rien avec
les Blancs ici
mais je peux complètement te tromper
enfin bon
je vois plus de scénario avec un gain
blanc qu'avec un gain noir quoi je dis
au pire avec les Blancs je vais me
retrouver dans tofu contre tour genre le
pire scénario
mais ouais mais ça en gros ça peut être
un scénario en force enfin évidemment
faut bien juger mais c'est dur tous ces
matériels c'est pas évident
je pense qu'en partie je me dirais que
j'ai pas envie de jouer avec les Noirs
mais je la tiendrai mais j'aurais
ça me saoule en fait si on veut pas ça
c'est qu'il faut partir sur le H5 chelou
parce que toute façon quand tu veux
jouer sans
mais bon
disons que
normalement tu dois pas dire que tu es
perdant quand même quoi là-dedans non
non
mais je sais pas si ça me saoule enfin
je sais même pas ce que j'en pensais en
fait
très vite s'équilibrer qui se passe pas
grand chose
on doit dire d'avancer pour les blancs
après faut pas oublierons là le B2 si un
moment il te fait 4 il va commencer à
passer derrière
mon truc c'est qu'en fait je vois des
scénarios ou les Noirs perdent mais j'en
vois pas où les Noirs gagnent ça
m'énerve ce genre de trucs pour deux
résultats
je suis content de faire j'ai trois F4
je bloque le fou et puis si j'arrive
à monter je monte
mais ouais mais en gros c'est quasi
forcé ça
comme position si les blancs veulent
pas forcément celle-là celle-là mais ce
type de position en tout cas celle-là
elle est forcée
oui après son Orchies
[Musique]
elle est quasiment forcée donc ça c'est
la une et la deux
c'est l'autre qu'on a celle qu'on avait
vu en premier
un truc comme ça
non peut-être que dingue il a quand même
malgré qu'il est raté
que ce joueur en fait les coups de Yann
étaient le foot des 7 fougères étaient
tellement pourri quand même que c'est
normal même après un raté de Ding que la
position elle est pas tournée quoi
et du coup si rien ne lui plaît il peut
en fin de compte te sortir un H5 une
dinguerie qu'on avait pas envisagé
c'était une c'était un coup du chat mais
j'ai du mal à y croire mais
en fait si il se trouve que ça va
envoyer un giga c'est combien de te
montrer en fait là frérot on vient de te
montrer ça il y a 15 secondes en fait
il a raté quoi il a raté quand même un
truc assez facile enfin ça a gagné pas
mais là il a il a raté juste dans ma 4
semblait donner l'avantage qui est le
coup le plus logique quoi a priori
confirmé par ceci pour
G4 en tapant sur la diagonale c'est très
logique
donc ouais lui il est parti
il a oublié que sur Rock GF était une
option et de façon en fait ça il a joué
vite en fait hyper vite et une fois
qu'il est arrivé là sur petit rock il a
plombé une demi-heure
après il se trouve que ouais la position
va alors attends rachuite est-ce qu'il a
joué ou pas
réflexe le coup le coup évident c'est
toujours dommage quand le cou est
évident et le bon coup de
sa part
il a vraiment que les gens prennent deux
trois minutes quoi tout l'enchaînement
lui dit gamin que j'ai pris un fils
n'est pas bon ou qu'il le considère
jamais barré
[Musique]
après c'est normal que les Noirs
puissent pas non plus être mieux quand
même après après avoir joué de tel coup
c'est pas internet quoi
perdre internet avec les Blancs parfois
c'est possible mais avec les Noirs c'est
rarissime bah ouais parce que déjà tu
joues en seconde donc tu as une sorte de
temps de retard de fait
et puis bah tu lui donnes en plus donc
tu as ça peut vraiment mal se passer
ouais
ça réfléchit
bizarre en fait je veux dire
en fait ce qui est très bizarre c'est
quand même une épaule aussi sur Fougères
assez vite
F6 il y a quand même le coup
bref si c'était pas forcément
[Musique]
que la dent et puis on verra mais je
comprends plus Yann là pas
personnellement
là effectivement moi je la comprends la
réflexion
sur sinon je suis moins bien faut
prendre je fais gaffe et ça doit aller
on va voir s'il le fait ou pas je clique
et puis on verra bien
c'était quand même un carrefour faut
prendre F6
un peu plus analysé que ça quoi je pense
pas
[Musique]
et
du coup H5 juste pour un qui conscience
sera un peu étonnant mais en fait je
prends on veut mais
il nous fait H4 donc en fait si on se
barre il veut se mettre en fout c'est ça
ouais
[Musique]
bon
j'aimerais pas trop avec les Noirs quand
même l'impression parce que des trois
madame elle passe quand même et puis
moi j'aurais pensé comme toi
franchement je crois pas qu'il va jouer
bon il paraît que ça va d'après l'ordi
mais bon
h ça te donne aussi beaucoup de bon là
c'est une partie il veut pas nul avec
les blancs mais ça donne beaucoup de
d'issue de secours avec les Blancs
et ça va être une partie animée et
intéressante
et peut-être ça plaît pas un époque il
cherche une voix de secours faire autre
chose mais j'ai du mal à envisager comme
on peut faire autre chose parce que
toute façon les blancs ils veulent faire
H3 au prochain donc qu'actuelle blanche
qui est hâte de voir se prendre un F3 ou
faire [__] en G3 mais au pire on prend
un G4 ou de toute façon on fera frangin
la question se reposera donc tassons le
fou à prendre
et puis là du coup c'est portes ouvertes
vers le roi noir donc tu as besoin
d'avoir fait ça pour fermer les cases
blanches
5 tout le monde tout à belle compagnie
qui arrive donc
[Musique]
mais là j'irai cette fois-ci autant
faire un peu plus dans quelle partie
c'était l'avant dernière je crois que
Ding avait pas eu de bol bah c'est celle
avec les Blancs où il y a pas de bol qui
soit si facile de défendre il a pas la
réussite avec lui dans une partie où il
a vraiment très bien joué et il a pas
été payé alors que je trouve son niveau
de jeu était vraiment conscient autant
là c'est l'inverse ouais il est plutôt
bien payé par rapport à ce qu'il a fait
quoi
ça devrait être les prochains coups on
va voir si clac la pièce aussi part sur
sur le plan que j'ai 4 à noter que juste
par acquis de conscience les fous prends
G3 c'est pas embêtant de ça fait doubler
les pions parce qu'on va jouer j'ai 4
prochains et on en avait cinq fou et ça
nous ouvre aussi peut-être la colonne
donc il a joué H3 ça c'était le coup
évident
[Musique]
F4 dans le même sens que h5h
ça me semble bizarre mais
ça sera pas joué
quand tu regardes quand même des trucs
comme ça tu peux les regarder
entre la maison
si même ça c'est pas clair c'est que
c'est pas bon signe
oui non je crois pas qu'il va faire non
mais il va échanger et on va voir le
sacrifice ou le cahier
7 pour pas qu'il y ait de sacrifice
mais auquel cas ça rend force cavalier
H5
[Musique]
pendant le café que dans les systèmes de
Londres j'aimais bien ok
de ça ce matin et c'est marrant que là
on est de nouveau le plan en fait il est
tellement pépère le roi dans ses
structures au centre marrant
mon époque il prend pas de tempo qui
considère comme F4
j'y crois pas il va peut-être le jouer
mais ça a l'air dangereux
faut vraiment être dégoûté par les
autres variantes pour jouer ça en fait
et F4 d'ailleurs
on peut pas tenter
ce sacrifice de pièces il fera quel
s'il pense que ça va autant faire wash 8
parce que tu laisses le choix ton
adversaire de le faire ou de ne pas le
faire mais je crois que tu es obligé de
laisser le choix dans le sens où les
deux plans on la réquivalent enfin sur
la suite en fait qui va les H5 et G4
c'est aussi très dangereux et tu sais
pas à quel poison il pire alors que
quand tu fais cavalier 7 ok tu es
interdit un poison mais tu renforces
l'autre donc les deux poisons soient
équivalents plutôt que d'en avoir un
nettement plus toxique que l'autre
partie plein de toxicité hein partie
toxique
ok bon bah écoute on va avoir une sorte
de petit combat de rue
on va avoir meding bon je sais pas
peut-être qu'il est content en fait
enfin parce qu'en fait c'est ce qui
voulait avant la partie juste il aurait
pu avoir encore mieux que ça et
je sais pas à quel point on a rendu
compte ou pas ou si su ou si il est
content et qui mais globalement c'est
vrai que tu lui dis ce matin à 10h du
matin après 15 coups tu as ça peut-être
qu'il signe direct
qui s'est passé ou pas mais que il a une
partie qui joue et qui sait bah si il
joue bien maintenant et qui gagne il
revient dans le match quoi il a pas un
truc où il s'est fait sécher et réciter
son bun qui demande qu'il a jamais
compris pourquoi j'étais obligé de se
lever entre chaque coup bah en fait sont
pas du tout obligés ils le font parce
qu'ils veulent mais
par exemple on les force pas en fait là
le timing de Ding de se lever après H3
d'un point m3 et de perdre 3 minutes net
à la pendule c'était assez bête
après peut-être il est vraiment besoin
d'aller aux toilettes ou quoi
donc il voulait pour en passer quelque
chose de pièces
ça n'intéressait pas donc on va à priori
voir du calage 5 G4
qui est H5 il y a pas de
contre-indication ça va être le coup
logique
mais peut-être on peut avoir d'autres
ordres de coups peut-être que je sais
pas d'abord mais je vois pas
de toute façon quand bien même tu ferais
bon on va dire ouais fin qui avait léger
6 maintenant tu as plus vraiment qu'à
prendre F5 non donc autrement autant
commencer par cavalier H5 qui est le
coup tu es sûr que tu vas jouer après tu
vois tu vas à droite ou à gauche ton
droit
en gros H1 c'est plus rapide parce que
tu t'as dit avec la tour qui est
enceinte bien joué normal mais
en H1 bien sûr c'est que je s’ouvre tu
es plus dans les courants d'air sur une
tour geste histoire H6 alors qu'en effet
le roi
donc c'est un côté
rassurant
il fait roi change G3 tours géante et
après il pousse c'est pas bah il est
logique
[Musique]
une fois que tu le dis tu dis ah ouais
c'est pas absurde
mais tu aurais l'impression de te
laisser
franchement c'est joli plan mais là
mais bon après on en parler ce matin et
aussi parce que en fait on a une autre
version du roi enfin en haut regardez
quoi regardez son caillot 7 déjà
mais bon il y a un temps d'écart il y a
pas le 7 c'est au nord de jouer donc
tu peux
tu peux faire wash en fait c'est plus la
même que tout à l'heure mais sur
cavaliers ici si tu bouffes
ou pas
G4
faire tourger pour renforcer une fois je
pour faire une fourchette ou répéter les
coups
il a pas trop réfléchi je pense qu'il a
eu raison
pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont pas mieux
c'est aussi bête que ça va ça arrive
assez souvent aux échecs en fait
l'ordi va chaque fois te donner ce qu'il
pense être objectif et là en fait si par
exemple il donne zéro peut-être parce
que la une elle croit acheter un tour
j'ai un fou H2 on se reparle on va y
avoir des îles on revient c'est ce qui
jugent être objectivement le meilleur
bah il se trouve que c'est nul donc il
va pas dire autre chose après
humainement bah déjà en partie tu as pas
l'évaluation de l'ordi
donc tu en sais rien et donc même quand
il y a des trucs comme ça tu peux te
sentir mal ou quoi mais
où tu veux te sentir bien alors tu ne
l'es pas
bon alors on va voir de quel côté il
tourne avec son roi
bon je pense qu'il va les rachat
de prendre un peu le temps de le
construire et après tu y aller d'un coup
là maintenant qu'on y est
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on y allait je pense que
tu fais
et du coup la tour G1 alors ouais
d'ailleurs je pense
et il repart
mais peut-être faut faire annuler il
traitera une partie
ça dépend comment il juge en fait
donc quand j'ai vu de jouer
il va pas faire
des clous on s'enlève de la tour et
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire d'autre
un peu plus tu vois
[Musique]
vraiment
ça sera pas joué
c'est pas con parce que le cavalier est
tellement fort petite il te prend les
cases noires et tu joues sur case noir
on sent qu'ils peuvent plonger aussi
et que on risque de récupérer peut-être
un petit Punto ok mais ça je veux bien
la jouer avec eux
ok hyper dur à voir
ça peut enfin ça peut vraiment être un
truc comme ça pour le coup est-ce que tu
es obligé avec les blancs de mettre
pression
est pas du tout obligé de jouer fois H2
mais dans la situation de match tu as
envie de tourner d'y penser en fait
très bizarre quand je trouve
et torchedost et cavaliers H4
si tu pars là-bas toute façon tu fais
plus rien je repars avec mon fou
donc il a joué roicher
tu vas pas le laisser là on le sait tu
vas pas mettre la tour en G6 dans un
vis-à-vis bah en plus j'ai preuve c'est
plus ou moins une menace quand même pour
les blancs oui mais c'est pour ça donc
du coup là tu chasses
c'est on se prend qu'il y avait les H4
qui est pénible
et dame 3 il reprend du coup il défend
son pion il a enlevé la dame F3 qui
attaqué l'option et on se fait contrer
peut-être avec tourgé deux qui arrive
l'autre tour qui double ton âge de maths
ou bon un truc comme ça
même si j'aime pas trop parce qu'il
bloque mais oui il marche c'est nous qui
mettons les coups
tu peux avoir beaucoup de choses là
il donne pas fou H2 du coup
il donne quoi
Bruce qui peut enfin c'est juste que moi
j'imagine un épaule vraiment le faire en
disant bon bah ok je fais nul et voilà
mais
oui enfin pourquoi pas c'est vrai que ça
a l'air d'être solide de faire ça mais
ça joue du coup
comme F3 j'ai solidifier mon cavalier je
vais essayer de remettre la tour en F1
tour 1 pousser deux dames des trois hein
mais je sais pas qui est devenu
5 est avancer des trucs mais bon au pire
on va jouer
pas qui est mieux là mais
en gros je sais pas comment dire en fait
n'est pour ronde 2 du match peut-être
qu'il te fait ça sans trop hésiter vu ce
qu'il a fait la dernière bande avec les
Blancs
C4 Dame des 6 foncer sur la nul je pense
que ça sent vraiment parfois une
probabilité que ça arrive et ce serait
vraiment joli
OK
du coup c'est pas une qualité contre un
pion des pièces bien placées et de
l'attaque mais
du coup il faudrait probablement ne pas
faire foi de quoi et jouer la bonne
vente à quel âge 4 F4
qui a rien à toi qui est plus ou moins
logique mais j'ai l'impression que dans
dans la dynamique du match sur ce que je
vois de l'intention des joueurs il y a
de grandes chances qu'il faut
ok en tout cas l'année prochaine qui se
chie un peu dessus quand même il revient
pas à l'échiquier il commence à être un
peu trop
à l'extérieur
est-ce que ce serait pas une
réminiscence de son match là contre
Magnus la peur de gagner qui lui arrive
pendant le match là en milieu de
parcours en milieu de match de rester
aussi longtemps absent des chiquiquée
en train de reprendre ces mauvaises
habitudes là quand même entre le fou des
sept fougères 4 est-ce qu'il aurait pas
une tremblante là
ça peut jouer dans la tête hein
la partie d'avance c'est pas très bon
signe en fait c'est pour ça que je te
pose la question ça peut
oui ça lui ferait du bien d'être
champion du monde du coup
il soufflera à fond pour la prochaine
fois là ouais tu touches le titre du
doigt mais il y a encore un tel parcours
à faire tu as deux parties avec les nor
à jouer tu en as encore une avec les
Blancs tu t'imagines mal perdre mais bon
si tu es plus en état de jouer c'est
très dur
donc avoir bon pour l'instant je viens
ok à part le fou des sept fuj4 qui est
objectivement pas terrible mais qui ont
pratique c'est pas si mal passé il nous
a pas fait de coups si mauvais oui
instantanément
je ne veux pas te voir
mais ouais faites ça quand même on est
parti
les lignes tu te dis que cette fois je
veux c'est pas très malin
mais nous bon on a les aides des ordis
on joue les coups machin
et voilà tellement envie du foie H2 dans
cette situation
nerveuse j'ai l'impression que même si
tu sais que c'est mauvais enfin moi
j'aurais été capable de faire cette
erreur mais débile de voir que sur quoi
H2 il y avait d'autres coups mais de
tellement espérer que le mec répète tu
sais faire un genre de billets
j'aurais été capable de faire cette
bêtise sur une telle pression
H2 il va peut-être pas voir ton G3 il va
pas oser peut-être il fait tout heureux
je refais fout des 6 et on répète et
tellement espérer le truc que mon
cerveau il me fait une zone d'ombre
et que tu vas tu aurais été capable
aussi de faire une telle erreur je te
jure 100% moi je peux le faire
en fait je peux faire la connerie si je
sens que l'autre c'est sûr qu'il veut
répéter et que je vois qu'il veut trop
faire nul et que je donne la chance de
faire nul mais là quand je sais que
l'autre il veut me battre si je sens que
ça va pas j'ai pas envie de lui tendre
la perche quand je le force j'ai trop
tôt je l'ai peut-être forcé à faire un
truc qui l'aurait pas fait sinon enfin
tu as de s'inventer une live de
complètement s'inventer un narratif
du coup je vais comparer enfin
objectivement en tant que je peux entre
est-ce que je préfère la position avec
la qualité de plus ou faire quel village
4 F4 si je vois ton G3 enfin si je vois
pas je me dis bon bah ok ça va et je
fais mon aller-retour et de toute façon
il a pas beaucoup mieux il est capable
de t'inventer un narratif ou H2 tu es
forte à faire une erreur mais oui en te
faisant
je veux dire c'est que si je vois si on
voit pas ton jeu toi cinépo va te ranger
3 bah il analyse sérieusement et après
il se décide il peut mal juger ça c'est
encore autre chose mais alors je vais
poser là je vais formuler la question
différemment est-ce que tu fais que tu
es tellement envie que ce soit une
répète que ton cerveau il te fasse
il te le zappe en fait mais attends j'ai
trouvé du ravoir tout court
tu peux très bien ne juste pas le voir
il peut en plus ça peut en plus
augmenter le problème et qui te justifie
moi je crois vraiment faut pas au-delà
des échecs je crois qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer le
même la force que ton cerveau peut avoir
de te faire faire de la merde juste pour
son propre confort là tu veux la
simplicité
qui va jouer
et le foie H2 c'est juste qu'il y avait
Mathieu qui avait une autre possibilité
éventuellement pour les blancs de pas
répéter c'est de faire tout refaire avec
son fou tu prends maintenant F5 il te
fait le truc et tu as F4
[Musique]
tu peux le voir
et à quel point c'est complètement égal
ou tissu ou quoi ça à la ligne je pense
tu peux te sentir confortable avec les
noirs
[Musique]
peut-être c'est toi qui donne la qualité
à maman tu reprends le F tu me dis F5
non mais vu que ça fait pas peur que
rien fait peur tu peux vraiment penser
faire la répète
que Ding est sué de pas voir je vais
prendre F6 et que nepo ne pense pas ça
de qualité comme l'autre fois chacun son
connerie et que ce soit moins grave
aussi sa connerie mais minime mais en
fait
c'est pas en foutu mais c'est vraiment
chaud quoi
et donc pour finir oui sur ton G1 a
priori donc faut H2 peut-être moins bon
effectivement que les H4 dame bouge et
F4 mais ça je pense que tu es enfin si
tu as si avec les Blancs tu vas te
ranger un tour G3 et que tu vois cette
ligne tu vois pas pourquoi tu serais
mécontent là je vois que l'ordi propose
un coup comme G5 franchement nous sommes
pas toujours logique pour repartir vers
MG4
faut vraiment faire
ça moi j'aimerais des blancs je lui dis
tout de suite je prends les blancs tout
de suite
enfin la situation de match on va pour
être précis
je suis très content à cette position
non mais ça peut vraiment partir en feu
jeu qu'il est pas tourgé
ça je suis peut-être moins contente
tout de suite ça c'est joli
[Applaudissements]
en fait
parce que je suis quasi sûr qu'il va le
faire avec les Blancs
[Musique]
il est dur ce genre
il faudrait quasi faire tourner très
déçu
cette partie ce qui réfléchissent pas
super longtemps sur chaque coup mais le
truc c'est qu'ils sont sortis tellement
tôt de l'ouverture
[Musique]
complexe
mais ouais logique parce que sinon toute
façon qu'elle est H4 arrive et la dame
doit bouger on défend malgé 4 ou quoi et
puis la tour si on a fait G4 H1 c'est
quand même pour ouvrir cette colonne g
et donc il vient de quoi
je sais pas
[Musique]
on attend des gens qui écrivent des
trucs intéressants sur Twitter mais pas
tellement je crois qu'il y a plus guéri
non qui commente parce que on a perdu
les vendeurs de gris
qui venaient nous dire dans le chat sans
arrêt ce que disait guéri il manque
je vais regarder
[Musique]
en fait Fabi tout on s'en fout de ce
qu'il dit quoi il doit être dégoûté
quand c'est guéri tout le monde vient te
dire ici il a dit ça
s'habille
personne n'en a rien à faire en fait il
peut te dire n'importe où il parle il
parle je vois leur live il fait que
parler
il parle tout ça en plus il va pas être
avec lui
personne vient nous dire Fabiano a dit
quand même bon maintenant c'est chaud
après il a été plus fort à son à son max
maintenant je pense qu'ils sont à peu
près
[Musique]
et du coup ton G3
HG qui est G6 ils analysent ça à fond
[Musique]
le roi noir est un peu vulnaire enfin
vite fait mais quand même un peu après
j'ai deux mais il a dit OK
j'ai compris pourquoi
[Musique]
je sais pas trop ce à quoi réfléchis
si tu es fâcheuse 4 ou quoi de toute
façon mais il va te faire un de ces
trucs
aussi mais du coup on est obligé de
regarder nous-mêmes en fait ce qu'ils
disent parce que on a plus les on nous
dit plus dans le chat
il est temps de réflexion Ding sont
vraiment étranges en fait et les moments
les moments ouais les moments les
moments où il prend du temps
ça vient toi être l'heure de la pause
mon Fab
qui va faire du bien une petite posette
là on a tout dit sur la position en plus
elle arrive pile au bon moment de toute
façon quand on reviendra il y aurait eu
la décision du foie H2 ou pas et
donc ce sera intéressant on aura un
nouveau position qui joue
il y a un nouveau nos chapitres dans
cette partie qui va s'ouvrir iwater
comme dirait Fabiano cawana ou Annie je
dirige en fait on devrait inviter à
nigéri sur nos live je mettrais du anniv
qu'est-ce que tu dis à Nice
Guiri ça s'écrit avec deux i yo le
double I
tu vas gagner 800k
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bah les gâté il semble que que Ding
est fait n'importe quoi
je comprends pas le coup il veut quoi il
veut cavalier H4 dames Détroit c'est la
seule explication mais tour G6
peut-être mais ça peut ça peut suffire
pour son propre
en fait enfin bon explication c'est qui
la CRU tourgé un fois je le répétition
ah il a pas vu il a pas eu le temps
qu'il prend les risques il fallait avoir
son running aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est n'importe quoi mais je comprends
le cheminement intellectuel quoi non je
comprends juste il passe complètement à
côté de sa partie parce que il a pas le
rock donc il fait [__] F6 qui va mais
par défaut entre guillemets c'est en
fait il a du bol il a pas le tamaka il a
pas le tour j'ai un tour G3 il fait
juste une très mauvaise partie ici Ding
et donc ça peut très mal se passer pour
lui parce qu'en fait le truc c'est que
nepo comment dire autant c'est une mets
dans la position avant foi H2 il a trop
envie de sauter dessus mais dans une
position tu dois jouer les coups il va
les jouer dire que tu veux pas jouer
pour nul et rien faire bah tu dis bah
tant pis je joue je t'attaque et tu
joues aux échecs de la partie
c'est-à-dire que tu pars du Fou des 7
fougères tu fais n'importe quoi tu vois
qu'après rock le mec a pas enfin
à mes parents que vous pouvez fix GF
mais tu vois que tu es encore dans le
dur donc tu dis hein je paye encore mon
fout des 7 fougère et là le mec refait
encore une fois aucun moment donné ça te
met en confiance tu dis en fait enfin tu
te dis c'est lui qui qui est pas à
l'aise pour jouer
maman oui 20 ans que tu es dans
l'incertitude on va dire que tu as le
choix entre un coussin un courtier tu as
toujours prendre le coussin parce que tu
veux pas que ça s'enflamme trop et donc
tu joues à contre-courant mais là en
fait quand tu es obligé de jouer les
coups bah tu tu les fais parce que tu
les fais en fait
voilà le gâté il a pas très bien joué
bon ok quand même l'air du coup un
mégalogique
et j'imagine bah comme tu me signale que
Dame des trois ça peut être ça va être
la suite s'il peut pas jouer deux pour
une autre raison
alors après bah là il y a peut-être
d'autres choix pour les normes étranger
6 c'est quand même ce qu'on veut
regarder depuis tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est peut-être faire tourner espérer
que l'autre fasse fout H2 et enfin
[Musique]
décevant cette partie côté Ding pour le
moment on avait pris on avait promis
l'enfer
c'est lui qui
à Yann mais finalement c'est Ding qui
tient pas la pression pour le moment
pourtant c'est son type de position donc
voilà c'est la pression ça s'explique
pas autrement
ce qu'il y a de jouer
il est mauvais
ce maïs de Momo ça ça voudrait quelque
chose sur le match quoi après la ronde
de casse tout après après la rendre 4
c'est bon on joue le titre les amis on
repère on regagne on est René et puis
depuis on est des maïs voilà et là
les amis il est mauvais il est nul
on joue le titre Les Amis ici la sauve
les peaux n'a jamais gagné une peinture
champion du monde jamais jamais de sa
vie et la trois trois fois trois fois
gagne qu'est-ce que c'est
les quatre peut-être bientôt quoi
[Musique]
c'est propre le Fab ah oui
non mais là oui ça peut être plus ou
moins la dernière partie c'est en fait
si il perd celle-là la prochaine ça fait
nul rapide est terminée quoi
sur ce on va vous casser une télé quoi
derrière les écrans là mais
sérieux le problème c'est que
mais c'est que je sais pas où il croit
qu'il joue bien en fait
c'est juste il se met en danger mais
c'est pas lui qui a porté
tu lui donnes une position avantageuse
il en fait rien
tout seul quoi
[Musique]
c'est plus mis trop Glou c'est mis trop
glou glou il se noie sous la pression
les amis
on va mettre une pancarte
il a une tête de ère Germain sur une
pancarte une mauvaise idée
[Musique]
il continue à casser des télés ou pas je
pense hein mais je n'ai pas eu depuis un
moment
de chez nous voilà
[Rires]
cavalier H4 il retente qu'après poussé
devant ces catins j'ai très peur pour
lui en fait je crois qu'il a imposé
parce que
en fait je vois pas l'idée humainement
déjà il leur dit des approfs
complètement donc il y a double problème
je comprends ce qu'il fait mais je
comprends pas les coups
là c'est ouais bon bah tu as passé ton
tour
dans une position hyper tendue
il fait n'importe quoi
ah c'est trop
même nul c'est chaud ouais la nul c'est
devenu
difficilement il donne une répète ou qui
moins perpète ou je ne sais quoi mais là
un époux en forme il peut te terminer
quoi il va te jouer les coups agressif
[Musique]
et karena doivent bouillir de voir ce
championnat je pense pas
du coup ça explique mal le foot qui est
complètement à côté quoi alors peut-être
que j'ai une explication
c'est quand il prend moi admettons prise
il peut avoir des fous B3 mais alors bon
mais après il peut avoir le bol enfin
que Yann du coup enfin si tient la
position genre
non mais c'est triste oui mais c'est
déjà triste et tu joues pour nul avec
les Blancs et tu dis bon bah Yann il va
pas s'envoyer en l'air à me faire du F4
à me faire du machin il fait ouais mais
là c'est dommage il faut agir les coups
au pire quoi ouais mais non mais je veux
dire tu dois prendre cette décision
triste de dire bon je suis mal mais je
vais juste blinder il a déjà fait le
coup dans le match de de se rendre
compte de ses erreurs donc il peut il
peut devenir lucide d'un coup mais
il y a un mauvais enchaînement quoi
qu'il en soit
plus le bol parce que vous vous étiez
quoi c'est trop
peut-être pas la reine la reine est
magnifique
ah ce serait beau ouais de venir avec
les bols et lui faire tu as pas la reine
je crois pas
je sais pas où la trouver mais je la
trouvais
attends je suis en train de chercher
alors sur Youtube en fait vas-y je t'en
prie bon du coup
ça tente
et peut-être qu'il veut dire sur F4 il
fait des trois
ok je montre à Fab une ref et on est là
ah non la raie fait vraiment marrante
c'est pas un moment gênant
elle est belle
alors attends
j'ai 6
[Musique]
très bien
et même F4 c'est bien aussi pour les
mains mais bon je préfère pouvoir le
pousser deux personnes
[Musique]
maman difficile
il y a un monde où
il va la chasser même si elle venait ici
elle serait chasser mais surtout que la
soie ça va être F4 et elle pourra pas
venir mécaniquement soit ce sera ton G6
après il y a peut-être même d'autres
coups ça a l'air pas bête et F4
aujourd'hui on peut regarder comme ça
mais je sais pas les torgissement
qu'est-ce qu'on veut
le malheur j'ai l'impression qu'en plus
même quand tu fais Dame des deux le
cahier d'être enfermé je peux me laisser
bouffer
en gros
je sais même pas ce qu'on veut faire
avec les Blancs
j'ai pas de plan j'ai pas de je peux
mettre mes pièces
[Musique]
toute façon place les pièces
puisque ça défend un 6
ça permet d'oublier les tours et puis
peut-être un moment tu pourras faire du
f-prangers qui t'a donné la qualité mais
vous fait plein de pions et solidifier
au passage donc
[Musique]
il a fait tourner
sur la cam il a l'air complètement
dépité
il passe tellement à côté de la guerre
là pour pas perdre il faut vraiment
jouer le faire en plus maintenant
mais bon
c'est tellement pas le scénario qui
voulait il n'a jamais dû avoir ça vu
l'ouverture
incroyable
[Musique]
a été juste plus solide plus solidement
d'erreur en fait
oui non il a rien fait de ouf mais plus
stable
ouais bon après on va pas encore
de la partie a gagné
c'est pas fait mais
c'est en chemin quoi après à tout moment
ça nous laisse le samedi libre pour
aller en Italie un Fab on va parler des
choses positifs
parce que c'est un match championnat du
monde et donc c'est sympa à suivre on a
envie d'un maximum de suspense mais
après pour retrouver le sourire ça
peut-être dire que samedi on travaille
pas je peux être un beau weekend
samedi dimanche
on peut plus jusqu'à 100 Mo
magnifique ça peut être beau
mais il a joué les meilleurs coups
presque tout le temps enfin il était
quand même perdant trois fois avec fin
il a perdu deux parties avec les noirs
sur son parti et puis oui bon ça va
tout va bien que le hey game de Ding est
plus peut-être plus haut que le hey game
de dépôt mais que le Big Game de dépôt
est moins bas que le BM de dingway ça
résume exactement ce qu'on a dit depuis
quelques pas ça fait quelques parties
qu'on dit ça aussi ouais ça résume bien
le match exactement on est d'accord avec
le D
le double D d'ailleurs
F
[Musique]
quoi donc c'était moins
le produit au moins mieux comprendre ce
qu'on dit c'est quoi
toujours au max de ce que tu sais faire
et B moins mal quoi
Game c'est quand tu es vraiment dans un
état de ou toute souris que tu as ton
type de position que tu as bien dormi
que si que ça que bon et donc quand tout
va bien jardiner c'est plus haut que
nepo mais mais comment faite pas
toujours à maintenir ça tu vas plus
souvent être dans ce qui t'appelle le
Big Game et que là bah du coup Ding il
est quand même plus bas et donc c'est ça
qui compte plus voilà en gros c'est ça
qui te raconte du bof quoi
n'est pas plus régulier
ça c'était c'était notaire une phrase
plus simple mais du coup moins
intéressante tu vois tu mets plus de
mots que toi
le lit qui a joué aussi
pas sur cette peut-être mais en tout cas
sur cette partie non sur les parties
qu'il a perdu comme le cavalier 1 M6
plutôt dans le match non plus peut-être
marginalement mais c'est pas là-dessus
qui perd
non
enfin moi je vois le problème du leak
c'est que en gros les grosses infos pour
dépôt c'est que Ding il aurait sûrement
essayer de jouer une attaque indienne et
qui est 3G3 et peut-être
des quatre qui est C3 en cas de musswin
non mais quand tu vois ce qu'il offre
ouais mais quand tu vois ce qu'il a
obtenu aujourd'hui avec le cavalier F3
qu'il aurait peut-être pas fait 6 mois
en espérant faut H2 et ah fois j'ai eu
la torgée trois oui il y a plus de fois
jeux là
mais là c'est Z game quoi
s'il fait foi
en fait ah oui non sur les aventures et
du coup mais c'est tout en fait c'est
tout ce que ça a fait alors après voilà
du coup il fait un truc là sûrement pas
fait le 3 poisons mais qui il y a
tellement donné une position
en fait si tu regardes cette partie tu
dis le lit tu as plutôt été positif
finalement bizarrement c'est vrai que si
il fait d'âme à 4 d'entrer là-dedans
c'est pas dur hein le coup que tu joues
en belette après évidemment partie
longue c'est différent tu réfléchis à
d'autres variantes et c'est plus chaud
bon après écoute on était pas si
catastrophe fait pour Ding là parce que
a priori il y a qu'une manière de
vraiment être si écrasant avec les Noirs
c'est F4 F5
pas passionnantes pour les blancs moi
mais bon
si tu as réussi à te ressaisir moi je
serais confiant de faire nul comme avec
les Blancs
par rapport à la situation du match
donc partant du principe que l'autre n'a
pas envie de trop risquer
je me dirais bon
c'est pas bizarre ça avec les Blancs non
non mais du coup bon
je suis faim mais
ouais ok mais écoute allez
Melun tu es pas très bien que moi non
mais là tu es pas super bien non plus
mais tu dis bon c'est bientôt l'été il y
a les vacances les machins s'il y a pas
trop de grève que l'inflation m'a pas
trop tabassé la gueule je vais pouvoir
souffler un peu
tu veux partir en vacances je sais pas
tu vas où tu vas peut-être en Normandie
Rungis
ouais non tu as peut-être pas du
Deauville mais tu fais peut-être du
Honfleur tu vois tu as un peu de ce côté
là et tu tires ta nul quoi
regarde tu peux aller dans la commune de
Issou dans les Yvelines
mais après faut H2 je pense pas qu'il le
fasse mais qui sait il y a une gaffe
quand même possible et je donne 1% de
chance de fois H2 mais je pense qu'il y
a quand même un FO H2 dans le range
vraiment un pour cent femme
allez il y a un monde toujours il y a
toujours des mondes
est-ce que tu changerais la boîte Fab
quel jeu des boîtes là tu changes la
voiture
non mais moi je change pas mais il faut
changer mais moi je change pas tant pis
ok il garde sa boîte mesdames et
messieurs
pourquoi si un jeu Vava il y a ton G3
mais le problème c'est que là le
cavalier à plus de 15 donc ça c'est
quand même ça se voit trop quoi comme le
nez au milieu de la figure comme le nez
sur les affiches
les infos projets trois puis on prend le
cahier H4 et on ferme à deux
ce qui est un tout petit monde 0,1%
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout à l'heure qui qui aurait pu être
probable d'ailleurs mais là non
je veux y croire ah il a fait F4 je
voulais y croire
et il y en a eu il en a eu fait des
pires contre
Magnus ouais mais il était sorti du
match
[Musique]
pas logique après il pourrait se dire
non je mets madame ailleurs pour
attaquer à Tanger si
genre
en tout cas
[Musique]
on va dire mais bon
qui doit être fou en voyant le site de
Digne et encore plus petit que celui de
n'est pas
ouais surtout pas être très propre
ah c'est trop là
on nous avait promis une partie
d'anthologie enfin on nous avait promis
on vous avait promis plutôt
nous personne nous promet rien mais nous
on est là
en plus il se met mal au temps ça se
voit dans son langage corporel qu'il est
au fond non mais il est pas bien
ah le mieux qu'il puisse faire c'est
tirer s'annule et se garder une dernière
chance
mais bon vu ce qu'on voit
ah il est au fond du trou ouais non mais
il est pas bien en fait ça déforme même
plus de temps de lui enfin plus il faut
juste qu'ils défendent le mieux possible
mais s'il n'est pas fait sa partie
maintenant
[Musique]
donc Dame des trois jouets bon ok
c'était du coup attendu et
[Musique]
c'est pas facile
ce que Nico accepter est nul ben il a
pas de bol la digne de pas pouvoir
proposer je pense que s'il pouvait
proposer nul il aura des chances
d'acceptation
les gens qui demandent est-ce qu'il y a
une chance pour tout réussissent Fab
alors moins que pour toi je
donne
donc en fait il redirige sa dame vers G5
pour blinder un peu tout le monde et
peut-être un peu triplé
avoir du torrage 6 avoir des DF5 qui
vont pouvoir partir aussi parce qu'on
pourra plus prendre un F5 s'il a triplé
et l'autre problème c'est que si un
moment il y a peut-être ne pas jouer F5
du tout mais avec F6 et E5 et E4 et
c'est la cata
bon ok on va peut-être réagir d'ici là
mais voilà
mais ceci bien en réalité pour Yann
d'avoir un point d'avance parce que
c'est vrai que la position elle se joue
toute seule il y a pas trop de risques
et tu dis que même si tu perds au pire
c'est que égalité
un petit matelas autant dans certaines
positions quand c'est double tranchant
au contraire tu peux te dire j'ai le
match en main pourquoi je vais risquer
autant là tu as l'impression avec les
Noirs quand même que peut pas t'arriver
grand chose
elle marque de café qui demande s'il a
une chance de triompherding voilà ça va
être très très compliqué
[Musique]
ça peut toujours arriver bien sûr mais
là il a plus du tout écartant de Manning
mais c'est un deux et un 7 sur un flop
ass3
ça va pas être facile
très important c'est pas les cartes
je pense qu'il peut tenter un bluff
mon problème c'est que si votre face
bref ce que tu veux
glisser une carte
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça rajoute quand même du suspense hein
[Musique]
on parle pas de machette on parle de
vachette synesthésie
non mais c'est quoi les idées pour des
pauvres pousser bah c'est probablement
d'amener la tour à 8 ans j'ai 8 la dame
manger 5 pourquoi pas et peut-être faire
F6 et pousser au centre 5 et où vous
avez 6 de faire F5 pour pour péter le
pion G4 et donner le contrôle de la
colonne
donc c'est
à tourner vite cette partie alors qu'on
pensait que les Blancs avaient peut-être
plus de chance
non mais c'est pour ça
en fait c'est tellement horrible c'est
juste qu'il a pas du tout vu ton G3 et
ni Tour Eiffel F4 en fait c'est qu'il a
louper deux options ouais c'est
incroyable ou que mais en fait je peux
pas croire que ce que ça soit d'autre
parce que en fait non il y a eu les
mêmes coups
parce que torgien il a le droit de pas
faire foutage 4 machins mais on n'allait
pas perdre un temps à faire pousser deux
et compagnie quoi
c'est le craquage
plus ou moins ça va
il se passe quoi bah pas grand chose
mais il aura une grosse avance il aura
déjà 7 points il y aura 7 5 au score
après 12 parties et il aura besoin que
d'une nul dans les deux dernières rondes
pour être champion du monde et a priori
il devrait être en mesure d'assurer ça
des deux avec les pièces blanches donc
en gros il est quasi champion du monde
s'il gagne cette partie quoi
et j'ai pété il dit quoi ben il dit que
ça sent pas bon pour dire
ouais
mais il va faire dame G5 on disait si je
sais pas sur comme tour G8 est-ce qu'on
peut compter tout le 5 vous prend de
pour taper F4 mais il y aurait de toute
façon dame G5 qui protège tout
et qui menace d'un proche et d'aller
mater le long de la colonne avec les
deux tourelles
complexe
quelle autre partitions
si la dire hein
ça peut être tout le monde est personne
aussi
on peut pas dire que Ding est pas posé
de problème non plus le match est quand
même été très serré là il est toujours
pas fini la partie n'est pas encore
gagnée
il y avait comment dire il y a la
fameuse partie sur la Nîmes zoo qui est
censé perdre donc bon
ça peut être une preuve de santé le
match
non mais comme c'est plus dans des
moments clés que Ding a craqué que sur
le niveau de jeu global il était plutôt
bien mais après la le match est pas
encore terminé mais c'est vrai qu'on
parle comme si c'était fini
oui non mais c'est pas encore fini du
tout et il faut encore
une épouse ont encore des bons coups il
a pas encore gagné celle-là parce que
Ding j'ai l'impression que ok là il
s'est mis en mode je défends quoi il va
plus trop faire de coup
pour imploser donc c'est quand même un
épaule d'aller chercher le gain et c'est
pas fait
surtout comme voilà tu le soulignais on
le redit que niveau un moment c'est un
choix entre un coup un peu risqué
bon a priori pas mal mais quand même un
peu risqué ou un truc ça il faut bien
nul bon voilà
il peut peut-être choisir l'option bon
bah tant pis je fais nul j'efface cette
partie demain à nouveau il y en aura
plus qu'une
donc voilà c'est pas faire
[Musique]
là pour le moment
mais il se relève
3 maintenant
[Musique]
non tu passes un peu ton tour je sais
pas
alors
ouais après donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
enfin en fait c'est s'il passe juste son
tour il se passe plus rien tout le monde
passe son temps
si on veut gagner qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on avait envie de la mettre depuis tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
je veux dire c'est pas si simple
F3 et je blinde quoi
de sentir que tu as plutôt c'est plutôt
cool pour les noirs et peut-être qu'en
fait tout ce qu'il va faire avec la
situation du match c'est ne pas faire F5
et refaire ton G6
donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas encore
du tout fini quoi
parce que la tour protège
ouais dur la partie
made in a quand même de bonnes chances
de nul encore je pense
surtout oui
de risquer
ils peuvent pas répéter nul avant le 40e
mais ils peuvent répéter ouais mais bon
répéter c'est pas si simple non c'est
parce que
même pas évident à faire
complexe
quoi explosif
des save dame C3 j'imagine et jouer le
match en fait il joue le gain quoi non
mais il est vraiment en ligne
je sais pas trop qu'en penser quoi
tu vas pas te
de dessin qui a toujours 5 donc c'est
même pas une menace
et non il envoie tout sur cette partie
en fait c'est fou ce qu'il est en train
de faire parce que décidé de me C3 ok
des 5 est-ce que c'est même pas une
menace est-ce que je peux juste
[Musique]
et ce qui serait pas juste en train de
se faire arraché
ce serait pas ça serait le comble pour
un chinois
non mais je sais pas trop tu vois on va
attendre d'avoir la fin de la partie
quoi mais là je
ça va pas trop quoi
évidemment c'est pour ça la petite
blague on tente de l'humour
bien sûr c'est japonais c'est pour ça
que ce serait le comble
ouais c'est terrible
ouais ben écoute je sais pas je suis un
peu sans voix parce que je prévois qu'un
coup ne déroulement de la partie ni rien
quoi en fait je suis surpris à chaque
fois
mais quelque part malheureusement pas
surpris dans le sens où je suis
impressionné quoi
c'est terrible c'est terrible ce qu'on
est en train de vivre
[Musique]
ouais je comprends pas je suis sans voix
non mais moi c'est dur à comprendre en
fait
le problème c'est qu'il y a les trois
fourchette donc
ça sera pas son coup a priori et sur
dame C3
et oui on n'a pas dit sur fupron on a
oublié de le dire mais à juste une sorte
donc on peut pas et à chaque fois qu'il
y a des seins quand tu signes ce serait
pas ça
je comprends
si on prend et le cavalier qui ressort
pas de l'autre côté
ok c'est ça l'idée
4 si on prend si on prend si on prend il
y a trop de pions
comment tu contrôles F3
mais bon quand bien même enfin quand
même on fait jusqu'à Valère 5
à vrai dire même ça ce serait bon
[Musique]
donc non donc des 5 intermédiaires
E5 et là il a dû dire il menace faire
j'ai trois pions prend si on prend et
son cavalier H4 est enfermé sauf que
sauf que il y a B4 attaque la dame si on
échange tout bah on comprend bien que
c'est tout de suite perdant c'est pas
très dur ça à comprendre avec les pions
qui vont Adam
et si on décale la dame ben le cavalier
en F3 et si on va en E3 bon on se fait
échanger fou c'est 5
tours et
ça va petite finale quoi de plus un seul
mais bon
alors niveau ça c'est facile ouais
d'ailleurs des Français 4 jouets il y a
une qui a vu évidemment c'est pas une
bande difficile ça alors niveau en plus
que je dois dire c'est que si jamais il
a un doute sur dame C3 tu es pas obligé
de faire B5 tout de suite puisque en
fait dame prend C4 toujours pas possible
à cause de toi donc tu as d'autres coups
c'est doublement problématique
la ligne principale est très forte
mais c'est vrai que nous on a
complètement oublié ça mais c'est qu'en
fait là
c'est le coup qu'on a envie de faire
parce que on se dit bah je sécurise mon
pion puis je vais faire tourner de B4 et
j'avance donc en fait façon c'est dans
le sens de la partie mais en fait
c'était un doute sur cette ligne toute
façon tu as autre chose à faire
c'est incroyable
incroyable Fab cette partie est
incroyable je sais pas comment on
appellera la vidéo j'ai hésite cette
partie nous a écœuré ça peut être un bon
titre est-ce que ça plaît est-ce que ça
plaît pas
aussi l'appeler du jamais vu
c'est quand même du jamais vu là en
Championnat du Monde depuis longtemps
avec les blancs en face ouais
la partie trop la partie trop les gens
vont pas cliquer hein
la partie de trop
sur les échecs
dernier match il n'est pas il a fait
bien pire
c'est différent
il a juste il a craqué là il y avait pas
de raison de faire ça
bon oui il faut encore il faut encore
finir mais en fait j'ai l'impression que
rien à faire pour que ça se finisse ce
pour l'instant dire que on se disait oui
peut-être tu te mets en place avec les
Blancs tu blindes et que c'est pas si
simple de trouver un plan enfin il y a
en temps normal pourquoi pas mais que la
situation du match il peut ne pas ne pas
faire et que là il vient de lui donner
un pion quoi
dans le chat Ding a besoin du bug
tu es arrivé c'était terrible
qui passait par là
on va voir si la B5 qui est pas
impossible
mais bon ok faut qu'il ait le B4 en fin
de vente intermédiaire mais que tu peux
avoir envie de soit pas en fait non les
échecs quand on calcule les lignes il
faut toujours garder c'est encore des
coups qui forcent pousser pousser
jusqu'au bout
après c'est relativement facile je suis
quasiment espérer un fou projet 6 pour
que la partie soit vraiment ridicule de
A à Z mais qu'est-ce que tu fasses
d'autre enfin je sais pas moi enfin si
il commence à faire à trois machin c'est
vraiment tu as donné un pion pour donner
un pion quoi
franchement être perdant avec les Blancs
après le fou des sept Fougères en 25
coups enfin vraiment
les pièces il fait il faisait une grosse
connerie mais là en fait c'est la partie
dans son ensemble qui mais derrière il y
a eu des rumeurs après quand j'ai parlé
avec Bad ou quoi qu'il le faisait exprès
ce qu'il voulait partir mais je sais pas
si c'est vrai je sais pas non plus
des gens qui disent ça après ça j'en
sais rien mais là je sais pas comment
dire c'est qu'il avait eu le temps de se
remettre et plutôt des signaux positifs
quand même digne sur les dernières
parties et là il a juste
craquer
mais oui ça ressemble beaucoup à la
deuxième partie en fait
il y a le même déjà mais outre ça il y a
le fait que
j'ai fait le fou qui était reparti 3 il
est reculé enfin des trucs comme ça qui
est aucun sens quoi
on va pas on verra bien
le jeu de mots c'est pas mal
[Rires]
de raconter quelque chose là sur la
partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis on va manger en décalé avec Fab
parce que on veut regarder la partie
mais là ça a l'air c'est fini à 4 B4
d'armes français 4 cavalier F3 ah il
veut dame C6 encore et sur dame dessin
il veut dame prend pion prend et prend
le G6 et il s'est gardé la case F6 OK
il y a quand même une idée d'art sur A4
alors déjà il y a juste à 6 qui va et
l'ordi dit
bk6 cavalier prend E1
ok c'est trop compliqué il va pas le
faire
ah il se trouve que ça gagne mais c'est
compliqué non ça il va pas jouer donc je
pense qu'il va simplement continuer par
a6
je pense qu'un simple à 6 va être joué
ici et sur B3 par exemple pour essayer
de miner les pions tours C8
paraître le plus simple après il peut
prendre son temps il est proche de
gagner le match
il est proche de champion du monde donc
même si B4 donne - 4 d'après l'ordi et
donc un avantage complètement défisif
est-ce que je crois nul au 40e ben c'est
ce qu'on disait en fait il aurait eu le
droit de proposer nul il aurait
peut-être fait et avec un petit coup de
bol Yann avec la pression ce serait dit
ouais nul c'est pas si mal bon
euh on va on va on va effacer la partie
et le fait de pas pouvoir proposer nul
il a dû jouer alors peut-être qu'il y a
un aurait refusé hein parce que la
position était quand même excellente
mais qui sait il y avait un petit shot
d'acceptation
et là et là là c'est là c'est cata
en plus Yann a que des bonnes options
donc il peut même pas vraiment se
tromper la position est facile il a il a
maintenant un avantage matériel qui lui
a été donné sur un plateau d'argent par
Ding
s'il y a le match c'est champion du
monde euh s'il gagne cette partie ouais
il aura 7 points il aura 99,9 % de
chances de remporter le match
il a joué des quatre donc il part dans
le truc direct
dame français 4 attention quand même
hein ça ça peut être dangereux
cavalier F3 dames C6
ça ça peut être dangereux parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de possibilités cavalier
prend un il attaque ici sur dame prend à
8 il veut tout G8
et après cavalier prend ses deux on va
on va regarder la première variante
d'Ama 8 tours G8 dame 4 je pensais pas
qu'il rentrerait là dedans cavalier C2
dame C2
et Damas 4
Dame des trois et F5 ouais ça a l'air
hyper fort évidemment enfin après tout
avait l'air fort mais je pensais pas
qu'il rentrerait dans un truc avec
autant de quoi il fait tout rager 8 oh
une coulante peut-être là alors dire
donne quasiment égal attention oh là là
là là incroyable ouais
la coulante peut-être qui est partie
donc maintenant c'est quoi le problème
faut prendre G6 donc AG c'est forcément
l'idée et l'ordi donne C6 touche le fou
admettons un coup de fou à gauche ou à
droite donc il y a pas de dame dessin
qui change les dames je vais quand même
le montrer parce que ça ça libère la
case F6 donc ça ça marche pas et sur
dames C6 donc je prends H5 va me prendre
des 6 on n'a pas envie de base et si on
joue un coup de fou j'en sais rien
disons fou B8 maintenant il y a des 5
si on prend H5 et dépend aussi
et ça c'est carrément gagnant au blanc
et si on met le fou en F8 disons
ah il y a tout rec5 maintenant
dame D8 dame 4 et on va pouvoir
reprendre de la tour et contre-attaquer
donc tout rager 8 fou prend G6
HG dames C6
bon tour D8 j'ai pas envie de regarder
même si c'est peut-être le meilleur coup
parce que maintenant il y a des
cavaliers G3 et on va contrôler cette
case et ça devient hyper chaud ça c'est
juste hyper chaud bon ça peut être
encore mieux pour les Noirs mais c'est
pas ce qu'on voulait de base c'est pas
sûr qu'on rentre là dedans en fait parce
que juste là ça devient très chaotique
ah et en plus je suis retour des 8
maintenant ouais je vais dire je vois ce
que propose l'ordi propose carrément
dame B7 parce que GH il veut prendre F7
ouais là la partie tourne complètement
et puis on prend il y a de la tour plan
G4 donc Dame des 5 F3 ouais les lignes
sont ouf en fait
ouais
bah là il vient d'y avoir deux gaffes
d'affilée
il vient d'y avoir deux gaffes en fait
il a trouvé le B4 mais qui était
compliqué dame prend C4 elle a fallait
absolument jouer cavalier 3 et moi je
pensais que c'était trop dur mais bon je
dis bon il a trouvé il a trouvé donc non
il a fait tourgé 8 là il y avait foutran
G6 et c'était hyper chaud vous pouvez
même gagner pour les blancs
avec idée dame c'est si ça après mais
lui il a commencé par dame c'est 6 qui
est encore une gaffe parce que
maintenant ça donne cavalier F5
et puis on prend
alors tu es pas mat à proprement parler
ou il y a trois ok j'ai trois tours j'ai
de
donc là il vient d'avoir encore deux
nouvelles gaffes dans cette game
tu peux aller manger
alors ton micro est allumé par contre on
t'entendait on t'entend des autres ok
non je disais voilà
encore donc ça ça confirme le titre
qu'on voulait mettre c'était dit on va
mettre comme titre deviner le hello de
cette partie parce que là c'est là c'est
beau
là c'est la stratégiquement c'est pas
passé mais c'est dommage
bon après on va voir est-ce que il a pas
que F5
il a pas mais c'est hyper chaud alors
c'est gagnant houblon c'est gagnant
bon écoute on comprend rien c'est
extraordinaire ah c'est magnifique mais
bon faut a priori bouffer la tour
et D5 et ça te défonce la tronche parce
que j'ai tu te prends de et tu es c'est
mort en fait tu es smatchers
c'est peut-être terminé
bon les gars écoutez on va faire
priorité direct vu qu'on ne peut pas
deviner un seul coup
on va voir s'il prend la tour ou pas bon
à un moment on avait de la bouffer cette
tour quoi
va-t-elle rester impuné manger si ça
aura totem d'immunité jamais de prise
qu'est-ce qu'on fait l'autre
et fais voir juste je reviens le coup
d'avant parce que bon cahier F5 c'était
ok c'était le coup je crois qu'il
faisait mal est-ce que c'était si simple
bon on voit que ça ça va pas on voit
qu'on défend lui que sur foo prend et
puis on prend on défend latéralement
et qu'est-ce qu'on veut prendre ça quoi
la lune attaque l'autre bon ok c'était
ça le truc faut B8 vient d'être joué
et l'ordi déteste enfin ils te dis faut
prends tour il le cri de toutes ses
forces et donc ça rentre de cave qu'il a
regardé tout à l'heure avec vous bah
écoutez on va voir après bah de toute
façon ce qu'on disait les échecs c'est
dur niveau Montal et là les deux joueurs
jouent mal en fait et en gros qui va
gagner ben ça sera l'avant-dernier genre
fédérale
ça va ça va un peu ça
me rend tellement heureux les amis je
vais pas manger ici parce que j'aime pas
manger devant la cam mais c'est
s'il y a que ça
refroidisse mais je peux pas quitter
c'est peut-être la pire partie qu'on est
en train de voir de ma vie quoi ça non
mais ça me rend tellement heureux en
Championnat du Monde une partie de tête
peut-être que Monsieur Poulpy ou je sais
plus comment il s'appelle frérot en 1100
en ce battle avait mieux joué que cette
game
en plus Ding alors beaucoup moins
dégoûté à tout à l'heure il était
vraiment
il a repris une attitude quoi
mais je m'attends à tout en fait je sais
plus ce qu'il peut jouer là
ah c'est possible qu'on voit une partie
oh c'est peut-être là vraiment la pire
partie j'ai twitté de championnats de
monde depuis 100 ans
j'ai pas en tête une partie aussi après
les parties pourries c'est vrai qu'on
les a moins mais il y a des gars en un
coup mais là autant de gaffe des deux
côtés
j'ai pas mémoire d'une partie aussi
mauvaise
après il y a peut-être mais j'ai pu en
tête il me vient pas une partie aussi
naze
un an de Gael fade pareil c'était moins
naze quand même
il y a pas eu des gaffes des deux côtés
à Nantes galifon il y a eu un joueur qui
a extrêmement mal joué mais les deux qui
jouent extrêmement mal c'est rare quand
même
et la partie avait duré 1h30
là si Ding en plus Ding peut ne pas
trouver il peut ne pas prendre un jeu 6
mais je sais pas ce qu'il veut en fait
là ouais ça devient dur parce que c'est
rationnel ce qui se passe bien sûr les
gens c'est des grands joueurs mais là
ils sont pas du tout à leur niveau
normal ni l'un ni l'autre donc
tu as l'impression que tu jettes une
pièce et puis tu vois tu vas voir où
elle tombe quoi en fait
et bon on n'en sais rien du coup
qu'est-ce que tu veux commenter
et ça me rend tellement heureux cette
game pour moi c'est les plus belles
après c'est la pression ça s'explique il
y a pas de c'est comme ça on aurait pas
fait mieux à leur place mais c'est beau
de vivre ça en direct
c'est vraiment un beau moment de sport
là qu'on est en train de vivre
bah ouais ouais ouais il y a de la
tension il y a des rebondissements
écoute on va voir on va voir mais je
pense qu'il va pas trouver
ok mais tu joues quoi en fait tu prends
pas
cavaliers prend mais qu'elle prend ça va
pas être joué non mais il va prendre du
pion c'est des 5 que j'ai compris mais
est-ce qu'on peut faire autre chose
parce qu'en fait peut-être des cinq
c'est vraiment dur ou pas enfin j'en
sais rien moi je sais plus ce qu'il dit
ou pas
tu peux bouger le pion faire cavalier FC
c'est faut voir que sur pion prend puis
on prend de 6 c'est hyper fort ça ne
paraît pas un surmontable non parce que
tu déconnes pour tes tours s'il veut
prendre un G4 ben tant mieux on fera on
fera tout reprend j'imagine non mais
rien
de nouveau perdant mesdames et messieurs
il l'a pas trop dur Fab trop dur il
fallait manger la tour en un bon après
vu qu'elle est F5 et le coup qu'il n'a
pas joué le coup d'avant je sais pas en
fait pas j'en sais rien je sais plus
comme je vous dis je peux rien prévoir
là en fait c'est match de championnat du
monde Fab mais moi je pense qu'ils ont
pas assez de temps c'est ce qu'on dit
depuis longtemps pourquoi les Blitz sous
les rapides c'est pour voir la meilleure
qualité de jeu possible donc important
là qualité de jeu hein avant tout
ah c'est extraordinaire d'avoir deux
heures pour faire cette game c'est beau
ah c'est les c'est les plus belles Games
celle-là profitez-en les amis vous n'en
verrez pas beaucoup des comme ça non
mais vraiment une partie comme ça vous
n'avez vous enverrez très peu dans votre
vie il faut se délecter de ces moments
Fab mais ouais mais comme je dis je sais
pas je sais plus quoi dire du tout en
fait j'ai pas de coup pour les mains je
sais pas ce qu'il va jouer
je veux plus savoir quoi
tu veux que je te dise le hello
théorique de la partie pour le moment
alors il le met pas
mince mais pas le théorique
a priorité pas trop le bon coup ouais
nul cette partie enfin j'ai pas personne
doit gagner c'est pas possible
regarde enfin le coup c'était cavalier
F5 qui était mais qui était très très
difficile
parce qu'il fallait voir que pion prend
il y avait dame prend géant te reprend
G1 tout reprend G1 roi H2 et F3 ok c'est
vraiment dur
mais c'est dur parce qu'il faut voir que
sur dame prend B8 il y a torgée de
intermédiaire donc extrêmement dur et
sur cavalier G3 il y a tourgé deux rois
H1 foot Angers 3 ok mais c'est vraiment
très très dur sa femme et puis on prend
alors bah là je crois qu'il y a tout
reprend j'ai trois et tu reprends H3
matin
peut-être tu vois on se trompe c'est le
tour qui prend et on matte très très
difficile comme ça et surtout H6
incroyable il a le coup
il a eu un coup il va faire mal le feu 4
mais ouais mais je sais même plus je
crois même plus la position en fait on
en est on égalité matériel
non mais franchement il peut tellement
se passer que des dingues
il a eu un coup le Fab
mais je pense à vraiment faire nul enfin
je sais pas comment ça fire je comprends
rien donc c'est dur
mais je sais pas quoi dire
bah ne dis rien non mais ça a l'air dur
à jouer pour les Noirs en fait là tout
d'un coup
ouais j'en sais rien non mais tu as
trompé tes pièces là la tour H6 on sait
pas pourquoi elle est là ouais tu fais
non
tu peux te faire bouffer F7 c'est beau
quoi
ah tu peux tout faire bouffer en fait
voilà partie extraordinaire elle fait
tellement plaise
pas au final j'ai l'impression que Ding
bonne chance de gagner maintenant
ils ont raté tellement de trucs
avec conviction en plus
ça sans réfléchir hyper longtemps pour
le rater quoi c'était
ils avaient l'air assez
logique mais du coup ce que je capte pas
mais bon ben la toute façon on va pas
falloir y répondre c'est pourquoi il a
fait B4 et pas à 6
26e
complications durant ton C4 il y a quand
même pas de grandes raisons non je sais
pas mais moi j'ai tout dit il va pas
faire bécasse c'est trop compliqué après
il a fait le il a super bien joué et en
fait ils ont rien vu de A à Z
ouais ouais personne ne
comprendrationnel c'est le pétage de
plomb c'est inexplicable
nos 30e coup donc bon a priori ils vont
pas tomber autant mais bon c'est vrai
qu'à un moment peut-être que il faudra
cliquer un coup de un peu vite donc tout
peut arriver
on n'aura jamais vu ces erreurs sans
ordi aussi on a quelques-unes qu'on
aurait vu quand même enfin là tu te
rends bien compte qu'il s'est passé
n'importe quoi tu étais juste gagnant
sans risque avec les Noirs enfin gros
énorme avantage sans risque avec les
noirs et tu passes par un truc où tu es
plus du tout mieux donc si on se serait
rendu compte sans ordi quand même ici
c'est quand même là c'est trop gros non
mais on n'aurait pas eu qu'il y a 5 à
vitesse de l'éclair mais non mais oui
mais bon en regardant on aurait pu
l'avoir déjà c'est pas un coup invisible
c'est qu'en fait tu joues sur une
surcharge d'un pion qui défendent à côté
et qui prend l'autre enfin tu vois c'est
ça va quoi ça arrive c'est pas un thème
jamais vu quoi faut pas nous prendre
pour des Ben et nats
et en plus oui et la colonne G qui
s'ouvre ou quoi donc ça ouais et voilà
mais le truc c'est que c'est pas que du
calibre 5 le problème en fait c'est
comme je vous dis le A6 là
un dur de comprendre en quoi c'est
rejeté en fait
parce qu'en fait ça défend un pion
il sera toujours temps de partir là-bas
ou de partir ici pour bien défendre et
avancer et donc en fait il va à fond la
caisse là-dedans ou tout d'un coup bah
ça devient incontrôlable il y en a de
partout alors que la série soit pas très
précise pourquoi pas mais juste pourquoi
pas si en fait
cinq derniers coups sont des Gaves
d'après tchascom c'est rarissime dort 5
gaffes consécutives
c'est très rare il faut vraiment
profiter de ces moments
non mais c'est sûr le titre c'est
deviner c'est deviner le hello de cette
partie c'est évident faudrait que nous
fasse une petite miniature avec des
gars
[Musique]
dans le chat
parti de l'histoire tout de suite il
arrive ah bah ouais normal
ah non mais faut profiter de ces mots
c'est les meilleurs parties à regarder
habituellement ils font les meilleurs
coûts et là tu sais ce qui va se passer
et là tu sais pas enfin non non il peut
y avoir une connerie enfin ils peuvent
tout faire là c'est
on sait plus
très venimeux le haut 3 ouais mais c'est
ça c'est écoute aussi quand on a tout de
suite
la salle
ah bah non mais c'est là qu'on passe les
meilleurs moments bah c'est pour ça que
les sept battles c'est aussi kiffant
beaucoup plus kiffant de regarder les
échecs quand il se passe n'importe quoi
en fait
[Musique]
2004 détendez-vous non quand même pas
mal faite
comme donc
mais c'est la pression enfin moi ça
m'est arrivé de faire des parties
horribles ça m'est arrivé dans une
partie importante donner une dame en
deux coups enfin c'est
c'est catastrophique la pression ce que
ça fait faire
c'est comme ça
je vais manger mon petit truc je reviens
profiter de la partie ouais bah écoute
on va voir ce que je voulais pas mais
c'est vrai que si on fait le récap de ce
qui s'est passé en terme de dinguerie
donc l'ouverture peu importe pourquoi
pas c'est un bon choix je trouve
stratégique de jouer le 3 poison
qui fait sa dame C7 un peu mystérieux
mais il avait l'air de connaître ces
trois moi c'est issu connait plus et il
nous fait ça bon déjà bizarre enfin on
peut déjà dire douteux en fait vous
Détroit admettons ça rock finalement il
dit là-bas donc normalement ce qu'on
vous dites pas faire de l'ouverture du
jeu deux fois la même pièce si vous
pouvez éviter et là Ding qui joue vite
un autre truc alors qu'il peut faire
d'un mac4 qui a l'air cool qui enlève la
dame du clouage qui contre tout celui-là
qui peut permettre d'amener le calibre 5
bon admettons donc il se passe qu'il y a
cette série de coups qui arrivent et
Ding a joué assez vite en se disant
ouais voilà bon bah tu rock pas sinon je
te double les pions et puis je vais
mettre mon cavalier là je vais te faire
H3 j'ai gagné la paire de fou cool bon
sauf que une époque calcul YouTube en
fait tu peux ok la digue du tank bon bah
rien lui à faire que finalement quand
même échanger
là il me dites pas ça joue pas mal F5
bien joué le cavalier 7 évite les
sacrifices ok joli
digne qui va pour envoyer G4 pas mal
enfin ok là c'est une bonne série quand
ce coup je dois dire jusque là et là en
fait Ding
par Henri quoi ouais il fait pas bon
voilà ton geste plus ou moins logique ça
jouait il fait pousser deux
pas très bon ça c'est bien
il se place normal
F4 bien joué enfin tout ça c'est bien et
puis d'un coup la digue il nous part sur
C4 alors il prend sa chance pratique
objectivement c'est pas un trop bon coup
mais peut-être qu'il a jugé qu'il
pouvait pas blinder avec F3 ou quoi et
peu importe il prend sa chance pratique
mais bon on va dire juste un pion le
coup dame C3 B5 défend très bien A4 et
là ouais la grande surprise c'est que
bon bah s'il se défend une épaule fait
pas il chasse ses dents de cette
diagonale après je sais pas peut-être il
y avait un truc de ouf à calculer
là-dessus mais quand on regardait ça a
pas l'air tellement
d'être compliqué donc il laisse ce pion
il part de l'autre côté
alors que oui a priori il fallait jouer
KF3 là fourchette mais bon je peux
comprendre que sur le coup ça inquiète
parce que si on dit ouais bon bah double
attaque enfin triple attaque quand même
il fallait prendre celui-là il y a d'un
point 8 échec du coup faut ramener la
tour en G8 la dame s'en va et je sais
pas ce qu'il fallait voir de tellement
compliqué ou pas mais mais bon a priori
ça avait l'air bien pour les Noirs tout
ça bon il a pas fait
il a pas fait il a pas fait hein il a
ramené la tour là-bas et là du coup ça
commence à avoir des positions où il
était possible de prendre alors le
Cavaillon fermé mais il y avait des
variantes qui qui faisaient de manière
tarabiscoté
mais il a fait dame C6 d'abord là il y
avait ce coup hyper fort qui était raté
hyper fort pour plein de raisons c'est
déjà c'est des fanfous ça attaque des
quatre ça coupe la taxe sur la tour donc
des choses comme ça bon il a pas eu il
est parti il a dit il a raté il faut
prendre G6 qui était très fort puisque
après puis on prend on ferme le cavalier
bon après faut avoir envie de regarder
en fait c'est toujours fait explicable
c'est juste que peut-être Ding se dit
bon bah je peux pas prendre je vais
faire mon cavalier je peux pas donner
deux pièces entre une tour
et basta et que il se dit bon ben je
fais autre chose mais bon il y avait ça
qui qui détruit bien en fait l'idée
c'est que si le pion prend ou la dame
prend ça donne la case aux cavaliers
donc en fait on a rien qui était plus
c'est le cas est bien placé ou quoi et
si les noirs du coup se servent on prend
celui-là on ouvre la colonne pour la
tour donc là les jambes ça et ça en cas
de prise on débarque de différentes
manières alors peut-être pour prendre
pour aller là slash on peut prendre on
va faire un échange sur la colonne g et
tout d'un coup faiblesse sur la 8e
rangée faiblesse de 6 faiblesse partout
bon pas invisible ma foi mais ok
possible de pas penser il a fait dame là
sur quoi il y avait à nouveau le fameux
kf5 qui faisait blocage au fou pas rater
et il a fait faux 4 il s'est placé on en
est là mais donc il y a eu cette
séquence tout d'un coup qui ouais qui
allait pas trop quoi
et voilà mais cela dit je trouve que
maintenant c'est dur à jouer pour
pour le défendre donc espion qui est
faible mais il y a aussi celui-là qu'on
peut prendre a priori on gagne un tempo
sur la tour bon pourquoi pas c'est bon
d'ailleurs c'est le coup
c'est le coup numéro 1 de l'ordi mais
que j'aurais pensé en premier quoi
et en plus j'attaque une tour
mais peut-être la partie est trop dur à
jouer comme
[Musique]
des humains après c'est clair que c'est
quand même pas des c'est pas des mauvais
quoi enfin c'est une poésie quand ils
sont tous les deux 2008 enfin un peu
moins maintenant mais genre c'est donc
avoir mais clairement
oui bon c'est de
psychologique qui a joué
Dink c'est trop senti obligé de jouer
pour le gain un époque trop proche de la
victoire du titre de champion du monde
qui signait trembler je sais pas il y a
eu un truc comme ça quoi et voilà
mais
donc oui en gros ça je veux dire les
coups joués on peut être géniaux mais
après voilà on peut comprendre pourquoi
vu le contexte mais dommage bon
clairement c'est mieux pour les voir
maintenant il y a même pas débat il y a
un avion de plus il y a un pion de plus
le roi blanc il est bien stabilisé et
dans son petit coin pépère il est pas
faible
les sacrifices pour l'instant ça n'a
rien de spécial le foulard venu il
couvre les cases par ici donc en fait on
est cool et on a un pion de plus à les
lames donc on va pouvoir un moment créer
peut-être un pion passé faire des choses
j'ai à peine de manger en vitesse il y a
encore une gaffe que j'ai raté quoi bon
il a fait tourner fuite bah il a défendu
F7 qu'il avait pas envie de donner quoi
j'ai une gaffe est
mais en fait j'ai les deux pions
attaquer il a décidé de donner beca de
plus que 7 alors à priori l'ordi dit
qu'il fallait faire ça je sais pas
pourquoi mais il a fait ça et prise dame
là et on en est là ben c'est un peu plus
pour les blancs donc on est mieux
on a un nouveau mieux clair blanc quoi
non mais c'est pas encore gagné mais
pour qu'on soit mieux c'est sûr non
je te dis pas que ça peut pas regretter
mais
je pense qu'à un moment donné ils
peuvent pas faire plus de gaffe
non mais tout à l'heure c'était juste
c'était trop tactique là il va pas
gâcher mais
en fait c'est pas vraiment les gaffes
qui sont bizarres c'est d'être rentré
dans un truc aussi incertain dans une
telle situation c'était plus simple en
fait la bizarre Harry
Potter spécial et comme je te dis de pas
faire raciste j'aimerais bien quelqu'un
demande en conférence de presse
pourquoi avoir rejeté ce coup peut-être
qu'il avait une raison pas une bonne
raison je veux dire objectivement c'est
un bon coup mais j'ai expliqué j'ai vu
ça ça et ah oui d'accord j'avais pas vu
qui est ce coup là où ça ça me faisait
peur ou etc ok donc question qu'est-ce
qui se passe sur D5 je vois que c'est le
coup de leur dire alors moi ce qu'il
faut faire c'était pas ed qui propose
que là je me serais dit je vais
récupérer le pion madame Decathlon
je me demanderais le 5 est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir me placer F5 mais c'est ça qui
m'inquiète
[Musique]
mais c'est pas ouais non mais je veux
dire on va pas cette ligne
non mais c'est maintenant qu'il fasse
des cinq avec les Blancs il va faire
dame c'est 5 tranquille ou je sais pas
où tourner un
[Musique]
pour les noirs
bon pourquoi pas enfin je sais pas
pourquoi mais je peux comprendre
que ça peut arriver
ok donc si ça ça devient une menace et
que c'est dangereux
et
parce que c'est toujours
après tu peux finir par la voir
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que en
fait si tu vois kf5 est tellement grave
et que ah tiens j'ai dame B7 tu fais
plus MC5 mais des cinq je sais pas je
suis
ça c'est vrai que c'est ouais avec des
Torcé 6 en fait
mais c'est très ça c'est vraiment dur
pour le coup
pourtant C6 dame B7 en fait
le prendre à revers quoi il a joué je
crois oui note un truc sur sa feuille
monsieur
F5 tu t'exposes grave loin quoi
hyper compliqué
mais bon tu t'es mis sur la bonne
diagonale tu veux pousser ici c'est
surpuis on prend peut-être tu auras du
dessin que 5 tu reprends le 5 d'ailleurs
je me posais la question
que ça sert à quoi c'est pour ouvrir le
roi en fait
je pense à faire nul
le
ça peut faire nul ça serait disons
logique au vu toute la partie mais
enfin moi j'ai un son tout peut arriver
quoi on peut se prendre un F5 qu'on a
mal vu on peut faire B4 B5 on pousse nos
pions dans une longue finale on peut
avoir un dessin carrément pour le
défoncer je sais pas enfin là
attention j'ai 5 nobles pas la tour
parce qu'elle prend elle cavalier
le dessin tout à la chance qu'il a raté
là il faut j'ai 6 D5 ça gagne vraiment
la partie pour les blancs là c'est non
non je sais pas enfin là tout peut
arriver mais
bon
mais bon du coup c'est que
ouais alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand même ouais
pas un truc comme ça
et mon repère le pion
là c'est vraiment compliqué là c'est
compliqué que tout à l'heure mais
en fait
[Musique]
ça je peux prendre
et
je vais me faire défoncer avec ok donc
on revient quand en arrière
les 5 fois 5 Dame des trois F5 on prend
pas on recule si je prends de la
c'est
toi tu repars vers F1 on voulait être
depuis le début en fait
mais c'est hyper chaud
j'aurais peur avec les Blancs là
[Musique]
ça fait peur
allez moi je mettrai une pièce sur un
époque quand même ah bon
ah bah écoute au pire
il a perdu le contrôle de la partie la
position est pas si simple à jouer
bonne chance pour le
mais est-ce que on peut
F4 peut-être
pour menacer ça ça
ça
de Tanger 2 plutôt non
je vais remettre le Caillet
et protéger ça bloquer tourner
[Musique]
quel moment important moment décision
critique
et il est obligé de prendre en B4
non mais bon logique quand même quoi
d'autre quand même
18 et
puis il attaque un peu des quatre et je
sais pas enfin
prendre B4
minutes pour cette cour hein faut pas
qu'il fasse comme la dernière fois
la position est dure c'est pas le
dernier coup difficile qu'il a joué non
non
fou
mais il vient blindé moi je trouve ça
F5 il perd plus de temps dessus
qui pourra faire peut-être F3
un jour ou qui sait
écoute il a son plan de plus pour
l'instant il défend et on va voir je
suis pas mécontent ce coup à
personnellement
c'est plutôt un coup un peu en Contrôle
parce que j'ai des 5 machins c'est pas
l'air clair du tout enfin dure
5 d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est un peu plus qu'un coup d'un camp
d'attendre c'est un coup de blindage
en fait je dirais comme il y a beaucoup
de fautes dans cette partie il laisse
toutes les erreurs sur l'échiquier pour
l'adversaire c'est un peu il fait un peu
le spaski c'est un dessert a fait une
erreur à temps il va en faire une plus
grosse
donc je pense dans la situation de la
partie et tout pour moi c'est un très
bon coup je mettrais même un point
d'exclamation non ça va c'est pas une
faute
ça défend ça défend le roi ça défend
lâche 3 ça vous la colonne de la tour
franchement ça va quoi
il peut faire plein de coups
qui peuvent être corrects je pense que
dans H4 un coup correct
pourquoi pas
sur des seins qui veut 5
tours le pion donc je veux pouvoir
[Musique]
et puis un moment on compte tout sera
défendu à faire B4 et il va jouer
vite en plus là je trouve que fougère de
Tours 2 pour moi c'est de très très bon
coup dans la situation
relativement vite parce qu'il a pas fait
la bêtise de faire fouger depuis deux
trois attendre donc il fait fouger d'eux
il enchaîne avec tous vos deux
et en plus il se libère la tour G qui a
plus d'allocations à partir pour
peut-être laisser même roi j'ai un roi
F1 oui un moment tu t'enlèves
je te trouve un plan clair tu blindes et
tu fais jouer l'autre franchement c'est
autant on a été très critique sur sur la
séquence qui a joué il y a une
demi-heure de ça autant là pour moi
c'est l'inverse la Ding la séquence
fougée de tous les deux elle est elle
est parfaite oui c'est bien
devoir défendre un truc inconfortable il
n'aime pas dans cette situation
je sais pas moi j'ai une connerie FG des
5 enfin
la variante elle est magnifique
mais je veux dire ça va les nerf enfin
il va vouloir faire marcher un truc
comme ça et il peut oui c'est ça il va
pas vouloir la défense longue et passive
mais
[Musique]
partie étonnante qui peut nous
surprendre encore plus mais la digne il
a quand même ce qu'il veut quoi ça va
finalement que ça a payé je dois dire
[Musique]
pas très méritée par la qualité du jeu
mais là là c'est depuis quelques coups
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal et puis
finalement je sais pas peut-être qu'il a
joué l'homme j'en sais rien du radis
aussi et dans la situation ou quoi
il peut enfin tout peut arriver là ça
peut être des écrasants des coulantes
des liquéfiantes ça peut être tout ce
que vous voulez
ça peut être deux nul rapide parce que
les mecs en peuvent lui ils veulent tous
les deux aller au rapide de tout se
passait
ce n'est pas la paire il peut tout se
passer
non mais oui parce que la défense
qui était tellement bien qu'on n'est pas
à la partie
mais outre les ventes à base de kf5 ou
quoi que peut-être tu vois pas ou que
sais-je mais c'est le A6 qui pour moi
est incompréhensible
des 5 Fab félicite-moi s'il te plaît
le caca qui a trouvé les amis ouais je
le car c'était 5 c'est fini ben ouais
mais j'ai deviné bon attends faut voir
qu'il est temps
j'imagine qu'il va la voir
[Musique]
un truc comme ça qui pouvait plus tenir
la pression
mais tu reprends aussi ce dessin c'est
tellement facile c'était inimaginable ok
mais le niveau de jeu là c'est je suis
désolé ça dépasse pas les 2200
et ça dépasse cette même pas les 2000
filles là c'est trop le F5 c'est la
gaffe de trop c'est le clou de trop dans
le cercueil de Yann et pomyachi dinkin
n'en croit pas ses yeux
c'est terminé parce qu'on fait là il
veut
il prépare le incroyable la partie que
vous êtes en train de vivre les amis
rappelez-vous de ce moment qui va
rentrer dans l'histoire des échecs pour
moi c'est évident que cette partie
rentre dans l'histoire du jeu d'échec
Fab un avis là comme ça à chaud la vie
du Fab je chemin deuxième micro tous les
micros sont braqués sur fable
dans l'histoire des échecs pour toi
cette partie en terme de rebondissements
dans une seule et même partie à ce
niveau c'est pas tous les jours
Fabien lui visage qui vous êtes grand
maître vous avez été sélectionneur de
l'équipe de France vous êtes un joueur
d'échec chevronné est-ce que vous êtes
en train finalement de vivre l'une des
parties les plus importantes et
intéressantes de l'histoire des
championnats du monde d'échecs
alors je sais pas ça mais important oui
parce que bon bah ça relance ce match ça
aurait pu être la fin du match aussi
donc pour ce match est très important et
niveau intérêt bah je sais pas niveau
gestion des Denner tout ça ouais c'est
il y a des choses à raconter dessus en
tout cas écoutez merci Fabien pour cet
éclairage d'un professionnel d'échec et
on vous retrouve très bientôt pour la
suite
à plus tard
clairement la menace c'est de faire des
cinq échec au roi et dames j'ai cette
main
c'est vraiment la pire partie de
champion du monde j'en suis convaincu et
en gros juste pour vous compreniez
c'était pas tellement une grosse menace
avant parce qu'il espion qui était en
vie qui venait bloquer
bon bah sans spion
il est dégoûté ça il a compris qu'il a
perdu regarde
incroyable incroyable
non mais le niveau tension est terrible
mais
c'est fou ouais
il est pas bien
là il est écœuré mais frérot si tu joues
à 1200 même en sa battle on les fait pas
ici
qui vient dans le chat il écrit ah
franchement honnêtement ni ce qu'il faut
pas que tes peurs du coaching de
vendredi je pense pas que tu puisses
jouer aussi mal je te lis tout de suite
c'est ouais je crois que tu peux pas
faire ouais tu peux pas faire pire que
ça te game
elle est incroyable
priori il y aura pas d'Italie samedi
ok non
mais pauvrement dimanche parce que là je
crois qu'il est fondé
la sarde qui n'a jamais douté ouais là
c'est shonen de chez shonen là c'est
tous les Titans
Colosso qui vont qui marchent qui nage
et tout et tu as le peloton le machin de
d'exploration il détruisent les 200 000
Titans Colosso et je sais pas pourquoi
en fait
il marche enfin ils sont là quand ils
marchent sur tout le monde a des cons
ils viennent il est défoncé
non mais
alors que toi tu dis bon les colossaux
ça va quoi
tu crois
mais ouais mais il y a plus de coup là
pour les Noirs c'est trop puissant
mais F5 tours aussi c'est quand même
d'avoir prévu ça j'en suis assez fier
c'est en fait tu as senti le coup de F5
mais tu dis non mais c'est tellement
simple ça peut pas mais ça sera un truc
comme ça c'est tellement un truc comme
ça que c'est c'est ça ouais j'ai senti
j'ai toujours su je sens les je sens les
couillasse expérience
au monde qui a commenté le plus de
partie d'échecs en direct en vrai c'est
possible c'est très possible en fait
c'est très très possible
ce que j'en ai commenté une quantité
mais astronomique du coup je sens un peu
les joueurs mais là je pensais pas que
j'avais quand même c'était trop
elle est pas pire que les erreurs contre
Magnus ça là elle est nettement pire
parce qu'il y a des erreurs des deux
côtés et il y en a beaucoup c'est
là c'est tu te fais briquer avec 4
double fautes l'autre serre il te refait
trois double faute et un coup dans le
couloir tu refais quatre double faute
enfin à un moment donné bon enfin il y
en a un moment il y aura des réussit son
jeu de service quoi il fait un service
de merde à la cuillère et l'autre il en
faute quatre services à la cuillère il
est foutu dehors
après je sais pas j'espère
je n'ai pas à se remobiliser pour qu'on
ait quand même deux dernières parties et
voilà
j'espère que ça ça fasse des couleurs de
partout qui est des gaffes qu'on sache
plus rien en fait
parce que là en fait du coup il s'est
même plus des échecs
c'est la tétasse là
[Musique]
c'est que de ça de tenir la pression de
ouais mais moi je pense sincèrement que
ce qu'il y a aussi fait mal aux parties
longues dans un moment donné c'est les
plugs hein
je pense qu'il y a eu un peu trop de
Plug et que du coup on avait un peu pas
assez de ça et que ça c'est normal en
fait bah oui parce que c'est dur bah oui
mais tout d'un coup quand elle est plus
surveillée machin et tout bah c'est ça
les échecs en fait et on l'avait un peu
perdu pendant quelques années
je pense les plugs ont fait du mal aux
échecs aussi
d'ailleurs les parties sont courtes
c'est rare que ça dépasse 40 coups déjà
trois quatre heures de quoi
c'est beau c'est beau ce chat là il y a
de nouveau du monde tu vois et ça attire
les foules tout d'un coup bah là tu as
des vrais parties on a l'habitude quoi
tu as l'impression d'avoir un baron fou
il semoule quoi et là tu sais pas quoi
c'est ça peut tourner
mes trois quatre heures de partie c'est
le meilleur format ouais j'ai fait une
interview pour pour un journal et c'est
ce que j'aurais dit en fait c'est là ce
match aussi il est plaisant parce que
les parties elles durent jamais trop
mais peut-être que on doit vraiment
mettre le 1h30 et 30 secondes ouais plus
ça et plus 15 20 minutes au 40e
peut-être que digne n'a pas le dessin ok
oui
incroyable cette partie quand même ah le
dépôt il est en perdition quoi c'est la
paire Dada le problème c'est qu'il veut
me parvenir enfin c'est le mal est fait
un Benoît Paire à sa place et là on
voyait des pions enfin tu pètes
l'échiquier tu peux stopper
en fait je perds
ah c'est beau
quand même
mais Ding il va tellement être bien
cette partie tu dois la perdre tu es en
train d'exploser tu es en train de faire
un cadeau et tu te rappelles quand j'ai
dit si Ding pouvait proposer nul n'est
pour est sûrement accepté il a pas de
bolding donc en fait
il a eu du mal
des
je vais faire un petit tweet
les résultats
je vais faire un petit tweet sympa
pour amène le bol à nez
trop
il y a que la victoire qui conduit
surtout dans un moment comme ça en fait
je suis pas d'accord avec la phrase
quand tu fais ta
quand tu fais ta chaine
mais
[Musique]
en fait je suis pas convaincu que ce
soit une bonne idée de se dire
l'important c'est que les résultats
quand tu quand tu joues les 3 normaux ou
quoi parce que le contenu hyper
important mais là quand tu es à ce
niveau là et que ça qui compte que je
vais dégueulasse tu t'en fous enfin
c'est pas le problème t'es pas là pour
progresser hein tu es là pour est-ce que
c'est pas le moment avec la petite pub
obligatoire mais juste
on part pas on reste devant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs on est déjà de
retour
il se passe quoi si le cavalier vient
bloquer en E5
on va justement
ici donc tu es obligé de mettre une tour
en F6 tu peux même pas mettre ça là il y
a dames 8 maths donc tu vas mettre
celle-là et on peut de la prendre quand
on veut la prendre même directement tu
fais toujours
en fait tu crées même pas une menace
c'est ça le problème c'est que le roi il
essaye en fait on a tu peux pas attaquer
sur casse blanche donc c'est terminé
il y a peut-être commencé par rois G8
c'est ce que ça permet de défendre un
peu ouais enfin il y a juste des seins
le problème c'est qu'il y a plus de coup
là c'est une gaffe en un c'est direct
c'est net claire et sans bavure
mais F5 c'est
pas plus supporter quoi
est-ce que c'est Ding qui passe favori
pour le match parce que là il a quand
même fait une coulante d'un level tu te
rappelles le dernier match contre Manu
ça quand il en a fait une il en a fait
deux il a fait trois
ou une dose stress
[Musique]
es
je ne joue pas et bon après bah faut
encore faire nul la dernière
extraordinaire t'imagines
pire partie de l'histoire du championnat
du monde voilà ça peut ouais je sais pas
si on fait deviner le vélo la pire
partie j'en sais rien en fait
ouais c'est
ah j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas les mots
là j'ai vraiment pas le j'ai vraiment
pas les mots
même
Mazon title en fait il vaut mieux
j'ai pas vu le Mac les amis
ce serait beau maintenant il fait ça il
chante quoi il est comment ton roi j'ai
pas vu le matin
je suis pas dans le carré
[Musique]
pas tous il y en a qui qui gère mieux
quand même
pas tu as tellement envie de te jeter
intérieurement dans une rivière quoi
quand ça t'arrive
non mais tu te détestes en fait
tu te déteste tellement c'est des
moments mais tellement horrible à vivre
parce que c'est pas digne de soi quoi tu
as l'impression d'être une merde
réellement c'est très très difficile à
vivre parce que tu as foutu
en partie longue à cause de ça parce que
faire ça ça me rend fou en fait je suis
très capable de plus que capable de le
faire mais ça me rend malade en fait
ça me rend juste malade
autant pas jouer si c'est pour faire ça
ça rend trop fou
c'est pas compensé par le bonheur de
gagner une partie en fait non pas du
tout il y a une partie c'est juste un
soulagement c'est normal en fait enfin
j'ai fait un truc normal et quand tu
perds tu as envie de
te prendre intérieurement et te jeter
contre les murs quoi
très très difficile à vivre pour pour
Yann évidemment
presser le jeu ma pauvre Lucette il y a
quand même bon il y a quand même les 800
cas
pour le N 800k
[Rires]
[Musique]
moi j'étais capable
non mais on dit un truc bizarre qui se
passe c'est que un moment tu ne joues
plus
en fait tu t'auto détruit
tu crois que ça va mais c'est sûr tu le
vois en fait que ça va pas moi ça
m'arrive des fois de détruire ce que je
vais de faire un truc absolument
hallucinant quoi
ça permet de faire sortir
non mais c'est pas une mauvaise chose là
juste de de
chialer en fait
tu chiales et ça fait sortir
non mais il est complètement dégoûté
que de se retenir là
il y a pas de mal hein c'est c'est comme
ça on comprend
il y a pas trop attendu pour le jeu
et pour foudre
et voilà
[Musique]
il abandonne
ah c'est incroyable les amis parti
incroyable
[Musique]
mais ça va nous laisser une fin de match
palpitant
première info qu'on peut vous lâcher il
y aura 14 parties ça déjà c'est sûr quoi
qu'il se passe demain il y aura 14
parties et peut-être des départages on
ne sait pas
la partie ouais il y a pas grand chose à
ajouter hein vous l'avez bien vu vous
même devant votre écran
il y en a deux trois à deux doigts de la
pleurante
mais bon il a il a il a explosé bon
mesdames et messieurs on se retrouvera
demain matin à 11h on va vous préparer
le résumé le résumé et
on vous souhaite une bonne journée
peut-être moi ce soir pour quelques
Blitz fiscalité j'espère supérieur à la
partie d'aujourd'hui ouais c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr je promets rien merci à
tous mesdames et messieurs et passez une